Wir hören sie seit Jahren.
Hier ist die Freak Show.
Wir lachen mit ihnen.
Bullshit makes the flowers grow.
Bullshit mit Doppel-O?
Bullshit.
Wir streiten mit ihnen.
Da fehlt es mir allerdings an Kompetenz.
Die sitzt hier.
Wer sitzt nur hier alle paar Wochen schon?
Wer ist denn dauernd in England, du Pfeiffer? Wir leiden mit ihnen.
Müssen wir wieder mehr über Apple ranken.
Aber was passiert, wenn die Mikros ausgeschaltet sind? Ist die Harmonie nur gespielt?
Das Doku-Drama Freaks Backstage wird es zeigen.
Sehen Sie Ralf Stockmann als Dennis Ahrens.
Na, die anderen Jungs interessieren mich ja nicht. Ich bin eigentlich nur hier, um Mitstreiter für meinen Bitcoin Pool zu bekommen.
Aber ich bleib wegen der Pizza. Martin Fischer ist Huckel.
Ein Glück, dass niemand weiß, dass ich der Einzige bin, der von Tim hier Gage bekommt.
Holger Klein ist Clemens Schrimpel.
Wenn die Meta-Image bald auf IPv6 umgestellt ist, bin ich weg. Dann heißt es Ciao Ihr Hinterwäldler, lebt Alena Steinzeit weiter.
Reinhard Rennfurt ist Roddy.
Schritt für Schritt übernehme ich die Meta-Image. Irgendwann gehört der ganze Scheißladen hier mir.
Alles meins.
Meins.
Also eigentlich sollte ja die Live-Sendung vom Camp im kleinen Sendezentrums-Zelt stattfinden. Aber dann hab ich den Dieselgenerator genau neben das Sendezentrum bauen lassen, sodass wir auf die große Bühne ausweichen mussten. Zufall.
Bald in einem Kino ihrer Fantasie.
Ja, das ist sie. Ich habe total vergessen, welches Zentrum das jetzt heißt.
159.
Die Freak Show, live vom Chaos Communication Camp 2015, direkt von der BER Bühne mit wahnsinnig vielen wundervollen Gästen.
Hallo, willkommen!
Genau, und das letzte Mal, bevor wir dann alle in den Kognitoren im Kino kommen, sind wir hier in Vollbesetzung angetreten und ich stelle mal vor, die Stimme der Jugend Huckel!
Wie lange bist du hier vor Ort? Ich war on und off, ich hatte so eine on und off Beziehung erst. Ich war schon Samstag da, aber dann wegen Arbeit noch mal hin und zurück und seit Mittwoch tatsächlich erst fest hier.
Wie die letzte Woche warst du schon da? Haben wir uns aber nicht gesehen.
Aber war ich da.
Und neben mir?
Ich bin auch seit Samstag da.
Dennis?
Ohne on und off. Das wird mir nur untergeschoben, eigentlich ist es hier irgendwer anders.
Wie auch immer. Dennis, der Original Dennis, hier.
Tim ist wieder zurück von der Insel. Auch jetzt dauerhaft von der Insel. Seit wann bist du hier?
Ich hatte auch so eine on und off Beziehung. Mehrere Male, immer so hin und so. Ich muss ja mal gucken, was hier so geht und so. Ich dachte mir so, oh nee, die schwitzen und arbeiten ja alle, vielleicht mal nicht mehr nach Hause. Also gefühlt seit Sonntag bin ich hier. Passt schon. Hat auf jeden Fall schon ordentlich Teng eingefahren.
Mit Gesamtmischpoco und Soße und Schaf und so.
Volles Programm.
Okay, da wollen wir nachher was zu hören zu deinem tollen englischen Camper, den du da mitgebracht hast. Ich hab den noch nicht gesehen.
Bist du noch leiser als ich?
Ja, ich bin immer leiser als du.
Willst du noch so?
Ja oder nein?
Vielleicht muss Clemens das Mikro einfach mehr.
Noch dich noch, entweder ich aber.
Ja?
Du bist auch da. Ja, ich bin auch da.
Ich bin oft, oft und oft da. Seit Freitag immer mal so on und off. Ich hab ja hier oben einen Landsitz um die Ecke. Wie war nochmal die Hausnummer? Die Hausnummer? 19.
Und die Straße?
Seestraße. Nützt dir nüscht, weil hier gibt's massenhaft davon. Bis der Arzt kommt. Jedes Dorf hat hier eine Seestraße.
Aber ich meine, Landsitz impliziert ja irgendwie, dass es eine Straße ist, wo es auch nur eine Hausnummer gibt.
Nee, die machen das hier oben ganz besonders toll. Sie glauben, dass so eine Nummer unglaublich wertvoll und selten sind. Deswegen gehen die selbst bei uns in unserem Dorf, wo vielleicht so 80 People wohnen insgesamt, gehen die Hausnummern hoch bis R. Also immer eine Zahl und dann noch R und was dahinten dran.
Für?
19 R zum Beispiel.
Aber es gibt jetzt nicht 19 P, oder?
Doch, 19 P gibt's auch. Aber wie gesagt, ich hab keine Ahnung, warum die das so machen. Die sind auch kreuzend quer durcheinander. Diese Seestraße geht in alle vier Richtungen und alle ist Seestraße.
Kann man sich das dann aussuchen?
Nein.
Gibt's denn ein See?
Sie wollten mir bewusst lachen. Ich hab übrigens 19 P und sie wollten mir 19 O geben. Und hab ich gesagt, nee, das findet der scheiß Vogel von DHL nicht. Der sucht dann nämlich die Seestraße 190. Der hätte gerne kein O. Das war auch dramatisch mit DHL, aber inzwischen haben sie es kapiert.
Und jetzt ärgert sich dein Happer?
Nee, sie haben die echt ausgelassen.
Wie auch immer. Start Nummer 5, Roddy. Dessen Anwesenheit noch am seitenden Pfaden hängen.
Seit wann hast du denn ein Ticket?
Weiß nicht. Naja, so ein Verpeilerticket heißt.
Seit wann hast du denn? Seit wann hast du denn ein Bändchen?
Bändchen hast du ja erst, wenn du hier bist.
Mittwoch.
Ist jetzt nicht sehr viel mehr verpeilt als alle anderen.
Null hab ich auch. Aber Dennis, sei mal ganz leise. Ich hab aus unbestätigen Quellen gehört, dass du auch noch ein Verpeilerticket brauchtest.
Gut, womit die Vorstellungsrunde halbwegs abgeschlossen wäre. Und ja, jetzt haben wir eigentlich auch keine Themen mehr, oder?
Doch, haben wir. Ich hab nämlich Netz, übrigens nur so nebenbei. Wir schimpfen immer so viel auf die Telekom. Ich hab's jetzt die letzten Male nicht gemacht und bin gleich angemautzt worden, was denn mit mir los sei. Ob ich denn jetzt irgendwie Aktien hätte von der Telekom oder so. Aber man darf die auch mal dafür loben, weil während die ganzen Hipster mit ihren O2 und E-Plus und Base-Handys hier alle sagen, dass sie doch wahnsinnige GPS-Abdeckung haben, hab ich hier mit Telekom LTE. Und das funktioniert im Gegensatz zum WLAN. Deswegen hab ich hier auch gerade dein Workflow.
Der weiß ja auch warum, die der LTE ist, weil der Telekom extra mal einen LTE-Mast eingesetzt hat.
Und so macht man das als ordentlicher Preiser. So, da hast du dein Workflow.
Da hat sich das Telekom-Opfersein endlich mal gelohnt.
So, Feedback, iBox-Thinking.
Den drehen wir nachher um.
Warte, wir haben eine Sendungsvorbereitung.
Das ist ja ganz was Neues.
Was mit den Selektoren?
You are not connected to the Internet. Was mag das wohl bedeuten?
Weil dein Muckelhausen nicht funktioniert.
Nein, mein Muckelhausen hält sich hier zurück, weil man darf hier nicht so rumsenden.
Wollen wir gleich mal über das Netz hier reden?
Hast du da Erkenntnisse? Ja, habe Erkenntnisse. Nein, mag ich nicht drüber reden, weil ich auch nicht mag, dass die auf meine ITF-Meetings kommen, mir da was über meinen WLAN erzählen.
Naja, ich meine, man kann ja jetzt mal Dinge, die offensichtlich sind.
Ja, hier gibt es ein Netz, und die finden, die machen das eigentlich ziemlich gut, abgesehen davon von der Nummer, dass ihnen immer irgendein Eichhorn den Ablink durchknabbert. Was übrigens echt eine harte Nummer ist. Jetzt muss man schon sagen, dass die das auch so schnell immer wieder finden. Für die Leute, die das nicht wissen genau, die haben hier echt eine Glasfaser von Hand noch mal ausgerollt, so 1,8 Kilometer. Die geht doch einmal über oder unter der Havel durch. Ich weiß das noch nicht genau. Durch die Havel. Also reingeschmissen einfach, mit einem Anker reingeschmissen.
Abschallt Zehkheim.
Und dann hängt das hinten an einem Strommast und alles schön von Hand gelegt, von Hand gespleißt. Das finde ich schon sehr ordentlich.
Und dann haben sie es mit Leberwurst eingeschmiert?
Nein, es wird ja gut gemutmaßt dadurch, dass das Kaya gemacht hat oder Frabz auch hier genannt wird und der den ganzen Tag Schnitzel frisst. Dass der einfach mit seinen Schnitzelfingern an dem Ding dran war und deswegen die Viecher sich immer daran verweiten. Aber das ist nur ein Gerücht. Ich glaube auch nicht an die Eichhörnchen. Ich glaube eher daran, dass das ein Marder ist.
Er meinte auch etwas kleinlaut, man hätte nur wenige Cent mehr pro Meter ausgeben müssen, dann hätte man auch noch Nagerschutz. Kann ja keiner jetzt ahnen.
Da ist jetzt Brandenburg Nagetiere vorgehalten. Hätte ja mal jemand fragen können, der Ahnung davon hat.
Ja, da gibt es ja dieses schöne Brandenburglied, da geht es ja auch schon mit den Biesamratten und so.
Billig kauft, kauft zweimal.
Ja, dreimal.
Den drei Nazis auf dem Hügel finden keinen zum Verprügeln. In Brandenburg.
Pack Nagerschutz ein, wir fahren nach Brandenburg.
Also auf jeden Fall muss man immer den Glasfaser im Koffer raufhangen, wenn man hier halbwegs Netz haben will.
Ethernet-Kabel im Rucksack war gestern auf dem Camp, jetzt mit Faser mitgenommen.
Single-Mode-Faser bitte, Multimode war gestern. Es gibt jetzt noch eine Rolle Multimode, wer gerne noch haben möchte, so 200, 300 Meter, kann man sich hinten im Logistics-Operation Center abgreifen.
Scheiße, das hat einer der Adapter in dem Zelt.
Er hat einen USB-Ethernet für dich. Aber es ist Third Party, ich weiß nicht, ob das funktionieren wird.
Okay, das ist ja spannend.
Was gibt es sonst zu sagen über das Netz? Die Kollegen machen das hier ganz hervorragend. Ich habe fast nichts daran auszusetzen, außer an der IPv6-Konfiguration. Er hätte das gedacht.
Wieso was passiert daran nicht?
Nein, Routen und so ist alt tipptopp, bloß die Verbreitung von DNS-Informationen ist etwas sperrlich. Wenn du an so einem Netz dran bist, möchtest du gerne wissen, wo dein DNS-Server ist. Dafür gibt es zwei Methoden. Die hauptsächlich benutzte Methode wird hier nicht unterstützt und die andere Methode wird nicht von allen Geräten unterstützt.
Wie genau welche jetzt noch mal sind?
Die hauptsächlich benutzte Methode ist, dass man das im sogenannten Router-Advertisement mitmacht, über die sogenannte RD-NSS-Option. Das ist der Router, der eh dauernd immer sagt, ich schiehe deinen Router, du sollst keinen anderen Router haben, neben mir und so. Der sagt, nimm mal folgenden Präfix hier und alle ziehe dir mal selber eine Adresse da draußen. Dass der auch noch eine Option reinpackt, hier, da sind IPv6-Adressen, da nimmst du aber. Das haben sie hier aber nicht an, sondern sie haben hier so einen Fleck an, was sagt, benutzt doch bitte DHCPv6, um einen DHCPv6-Server nach dem DNS-Server zu fragen. Und das machen aber z.B. Android-Geräte nicht. Übrigens aus interessanten Gründen. Das kommt nachher bei ITF, ich hab mich nämlich mit den ITF, mit den Android-Entwicklern, die genau dafür zuständig sind, in Prag unterhalten. Hab gefragt, ob sie noch ganz bei Trost sind, und sie sagten, ja, sie sind noch ganz bei Trost.
Aber wir bleiben jetzt erstmal beim Camp. Genau.
Aber ansonsten ist das sehr schick hier und sehr wuppt, sehr gut. Und ich muss auch echt sagen, ich mach ja nun selber auch viele Eventnetze, also das gerade hier draußen zu machen mit tausend Leuten, die einem über die Kabel fahren und einem durch einen anderen Scheiß und das halt so stabil wird, ist hinzukriegen und am Laufen zu halten. Respekt.
Genau. Also, ich meine, hast du noch eine These, warum das mit dem W-DAN so on and off again ist?
Naja, on and off again ist, ich hätte hier ein bisschen, ich glaube, sie haben irgendwie, was habe ich gelesen, irgendwie von 130 APs oder sowas hier im Spiel. Das ist dieselbe Menge, die wir ungefähr auf der Station haben für die Republika und das reicht für so ein großes Gelände hier nicht aus. Ich glaube, dass einfach die AP-Dichte müsste ein bisschen höher sein, weil was man hier sehr häufig hat, ist, dass das Einzennetz, was noch richtig funktioniert, nämlich das 5 GHz-Netz, dass man das nicht immer sieht, liegt halt daran, dass das in Ausbreitung nicht so groß ist wie das vom 2,4er und den 2,4er kannst du wie üblich nicht benutzen.
So aus dem Bauch heraus, was meinst du, wie viele APs man hier in die Bäume hängen muss?
Vier und ein halb Tausend.
Ja, genau.
Eigentlich sollte man den AP gleich am Eingang mit dem Ticket zu machen.
Nächstes Mal gibts als Batch einen 5 GHz-AP.
Kann man den hier reinbauen oder?
Ich glaub, der hört bei 4 GHz auf. Aber da geht ja noch was. Da kann man ja noch dran arbeiten.
Aber Legacy geht jetzt?
Ja, Legacy geht, wenn es halt nicht zu voll ist. Und Legacy hat halt immer das Problem, dass du einfach viel zu wenig Kanäle hast. Dass es da halt Überschneidungen, Überlappungen gibt und Störungen und hin und her. Und dann bringen wir hier bestimmt im Family Village voll von lauter Babyphones, damit die Typen jetzt alle hier sitzen können.
Babyphones, das war gestern. Wir laufen alle mit Decktrumm.
Abschließend der Kinder, ja.
Alle super vernetzt hier und so. Für Eltern ist das richtig geil. Weil die nur so, ah ja, ich steh... Hallo Papa, ich steh jetzt hier oben auf der Rutsche. Ich hab super Empfang. Das sind echt neue Welten so. Das ist super, das Camp ist einfach... Das finde ich jetzt auch einen mega Fortschritt in dieses Camp, dieses Family-Villager. Das hat vielleicht nicht immer jeder auf dem Zahn, aber die Leute mit Kindern sehr wohl. Früher waren halt so... Also generell Outdoor-Events natürlich schwierig. Und auch die Camps waren jetzt, sagen wir mal, in den ersten Instanzen in keiner Form irgendwie Kinder optimiert. Das war etwas, worauf man erst mal kommen musste. Und dann waren die Szenen noch insgesamt etwas jünger und noch nicht so mit Nachwuchs bestückt. Das hat sich dann mit der Zeit dann auch ergeben. Und hier profitieren wir natürlich auch maßgeblich von diesem Gelände, was einfach in diesem nördlichen Teil, mit dem See und dem Spielplatz und so weiter und den vielen Bäumchen und so. Und die Bimmelbahn fährt dann auch noch dadurch. Ich meine, gut, die fährt auch woanders, aber das ist halt einfach todromantisch, super safe. Und was sich einfach, was sowieso der beste Faktor ist, und das hat einfach was mit der Szene zu tun, dass sie einfach, hier kannst du einfach Kinder laufen und du weißt halt einfach, everybody cares.
Hier ist einfach eine der größten arschlochfreien Zonen, die man in Brandenburg finden kann. Sag mal, die größte zusammenhängende arschlochfreie Zone.
Du vergrollst unsere Brandenburger Höherer.
Nee, nee, nee, da gibt es auch andere arschlochfreie Zonen. Aber ich sag halt, es ist halt so schön groß zusammenhängend. Sehr angenehm, ich mag das hier.
Ja, was muss man noch erwähnen? Also der Aufbau war wohl...
Warm.
Warm, schwierig generell. Viele Pläne mussten geändert werden. On the fly, ja, schon das eine oder andere. Also im Sinne von ganze Großzelte stehen dann auf einmal woanders.
Ganze Generatoren stehen dann plötzlich woanders.
Ja, Generatoren stehen woanders oder auch nicht. Was ich jetzt insofern sehr bemerkenswert finde, war was man ja nicht bedenkt. Also was ich denke, was viele Leute nicht bedenken, was ich auch selber lange Zeit nicht bedacht habe, ist, dass hier einfach die Infrastruktur, die muss ja solchen konstruktiven Änderungen auch folgen. Und das ist ja nicht nur so, dass du dann auch noch ein Stromkabel hast, was da hinläuft, was noch das geringste Problem ist, sondern zum Beispiel diese Wasserinfrastruktur muss dem natürlich auch entsprechend folgen. Und während man Strom halt einfach mal, da legt man halt nochmal ein Kabel, bei Wasser legst du halt nicht eben nochmal einen Schlauch allein, weil das hat dann eben auch was mit Druck und oben und unten zu tun.
Und bei Kabeln auch nicht anders.
Und rein und raus vor allen Dingen.
Bei Kabeln?
Ja, hier die komischen Switches, die in den Datenclos drin haben. An sich kannst du Gigabit bis 100 Meter machen. Mach mal da einen 100 Meter Kabel dran. Der gibt ja schon nach 50 Metern.
Ja gut, aber das ist nur eine Frage der Länge, aber nicht ob das Kabel nach oben oder nach unten geht.
Wenn das Datencloswärter oben stehen würde, dann wäre das ein bisschen...
Das heißt, wir brauchen dann in Zukunft auch so einen Datenturm, der sozusagen über allem so prangt, wo die Bits einfach vor dem Camp schon reingekippt werden, damit sie dann sozusagen gleichmäßig nach unten abstreuen können.
Hier gibt's einen Typen, gar nicht so weit weg, der stellt diese komischen Jagdsitze her, diese Hochsitze für Jäger. Und zwar jeden Tag zwei Stück davon, hämmert der zusammen und fährt die mit so einem Kleinen, mit so einem Anhänger durch die Gegend.
Zwei pro Tag?
Ja, hämmert der davon, kann man auch mehr herstellen, macht er halt alleine und fährt die dann da...
Wie viele Abschussstellen?
Ist egal. So Zeugs kann man sich ja für nächstes Mal ordern und dann machst du das Daten-Klo oben drauf und dann hast du die entsprechende Gefälle für die Bits. Ja gut, das gibt's ja hier schon. Nächstes Mal ist in vier Jahren, dann haben wir hier alle Single-Mode-Glasfasern unsere Zelte. Dann hat diese Kupfernummer hoffentlich ein Ende.
Reiber notiere dies.
Ja.
Aber ich dachte Datendruck ist das, was du hast, wenn du keinen empfangen hast.
Und was ist mit der Datenkanalisation?
Stimmt. Ist hier wie mit dem Wasser, das Wasser hinzukriegen, ist ja nicht das Problem, aber die Scheiße wieder wegzukriegen.
Die ganzen verrotteten Bits, die wir wegmüssen.
Die wird erst mal durchgequirlt. Was haben Sie denn auf dem Tempel?
Ja, ich bin für die Datenentsorgung zufrieden. Ja, kann man auch gleich mal über Recycling nachdenken. Infrastruktur ist hier sehr schwierig. Was vielleicht manchen schon aufgefallen ist, dass so zu bestimmten Duschzeiten der Wasserdruck nicht mehr so da ist. Jetzt mal von Daten mal ganz abgesehen. Schlicht weil halt einfach mehr Wasser entnommen wird, als das, was hier da angeliefert wird. Weil wir finden uns hier einfach mal so einen Kilometer hinter dem letzten Kaff, hinter dem letzten Kaff. Und das ist halt nicht unbedingt jetzt darauf ausgelegt, so mal eben so eine Kleinscheibe mit 5000 Teilnehmern zu entfachen.
Hast du diese Cashers gesehen?
Jaja, das ist halt nämlich sozusagen das Problem. Das ist nicht nur ein Problem der Wasserzuführung, sondern auch ein Problem der Wasserentsorgung. Die Durchmesser sind halt einfach mal so hier für den Braunkanal einfach mal nicht so konzipiert, dass man da so mal eben so mit 5000 Leuten gleichzeitig...
Es gibt hier keinen Braunkanal, hier kommt der Ulf mit seinem Gültransporter und saugt den direkt.
Der Dixi-Fansch lürft das dann weg, oder?
Ja, aber es ist eine schöne Analogie zu dem, was wir halt sozusagen aus dem Netzwerkbereich ja auch ganz gut kennen. Das muss halt erstmal gebuffert werden. Und diese Säcke, die da halt überall rumliegen, das sind ja sozusagen so die Wasserbuffer. Das heißt, wenn das sozusagen erstmal so primär entsorgt wird, dann wird die Scheiße ja dann auch so richtig geschreddert.
Meinst du, das ist für Frischwasser diese Kesche?
Nee, das ist Grauwasser. Also es gibt hier so verschiedene Wasser.
Das ist Spülwasser und da hinten wird das, man wegspült dann gesammelt, damit es nachts wahrscheinlich gepflegt in die leere Leitung gepumpt wird.
Also es gibt mindestens, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr hier komplett überblickt, aber es gibt mindestens vier verschiedene Wasserarten, die man jetzt hier unterscheiden muss. Es gibt Trinkwasser, ist klar, Grauwasser, Entschuldigung, Frischwasser. Das ist sozusagen Wasser, was hier so aus der Natur kommt, ich glaube aus der Haft oder irgendeinem See. Das wird dann eben teilweise für Klos benutzt, das ist halt so ein bisschen nicht ganz so klar. Und das, was halt so aus Duschen so rauskommt, das ist dann Grauwasser und dann gibt es halt noch Schwarzwasser. Was war schwer, ich Schwarzwasser heißt, aber jetzt nicht Braunwasser heißt. Und die werden dann eben Grauwasser und Schwarzwasser werden hier sozusagen separat gebuffert. Das sind dann eben so diese großen Säcke. Und die Annahme, also die Hoffnung war, dass man eben so viel buffern kann, dass wenn so die Nachfrage nach Abraum eben nicht mehr so ganz so ist, also nachts, ja die Stoßzeit, genau, die Stoßzeit durch ist, dass man dann eben so über Nacht das eben so kontinuierlich wegschweilen kann, um dann eben mit diesen kleinen Bandbreiten, die hier in Brandenburg halt zur Verfügung stehen, das dann eben noch zu entsorgen. Und wenn es halt nicht klappt, dann muss man noch mit einem Tankwagen ran und die ganze Kacke dann auch noch irgendwie durch die Gegend kahn. Was man nicht so ganz bedacht hat, ist, dass ja so ein Sack auch ein gewisses Eigenleben hat.
Insbesondere dann, wenn man mit einer Sonne drauf leuchtet.
Ja genau, das ist ja sozusagen, es hat ja so Inhaltsstoffe, die arbeiten dann auch. Und da entwickeln sich dann halt auch so Gase und diese Säcke haben einfach so diese Eigenart, dass sie halt so von Zeit zu Zeit dann halt auch mal pupsen müssen. Was dann dazu führte, dass dann eben so entsprechende Gas-Fahnen so irgendwie sich über die Region ausbreiteten. Und trotzdem hat man halt die Backstage-Küche direkt daneben gesetzt. Das war dann so beim Aufbau nicht ganz so schön. Aber ging dann trotzdem.
Ich bin sehr froh hier im BER Village, dass wir so schön zwischen den Bäumen wohnen. Weil auf der anderen Seite ist hinter den Schienen eher so, fühlt mich so wie bei Mad Max, so ein bisschen da draußen in der Wüste. Und da liegen dann auch diese Kissen. Deswegen ist das schon... Er filmt uns jetzt hier. Da hinten auf dem tollen Display.
Aber waren wir da nicht eben sowieso schon? Zur Erklärung für die Audio-Hörer.
Und mein Stream, der ist instant, der andere Stream ist zehn Sekunden hinterher.
Dennis hat jetzt hier sein iPhone auf den Tisch gestellt und wir strömen das hier direkt auf sein Display. Genau, der Service-Point.
Muss ja noch meinem Sponsor danken, das hat ja der Erdgeist gekodet. Müssen alle mal klatschen.
Das ist das Display, was normalerweise im CCCB steht, so eine ehemalige Wasstafel. Wo kommt es her?
Flughafen.
Ja, ist super geworden. Da hatten wir ja schon mal länger drüber geredet, das müssen wir jetzt nicht noch mal aufräumen. Okay, also so viel zur Gas, Wasser, Feuer und Entsorgung.
Hier so ein bisschen Thema, das hatte der Ralf Kaspers gestern auch schon intensiv in Beobachtung.
Hast du den Vortrag in Gänze gesehen?
Ich hab leider nur die letzte Hälfte. Mit Hunde, die an die Wand scheißen und alle.
Ja, da war so ein etwas ekliger. Aber es fand ich sehr schön, dass wir überhaupt da waren.
Ich saß relativ weit vorne und hab den Typen immer in dieser Simultan-Übersetzer-Kapsel da gesehen. Und als der Ralf darüber anfing zu dozieren, was man so mit Popeln macht, insbesondere, dass man sich die doch genau angucken soll, um dadurch die Luftqualität besser darzustellen oder sich verinnerlichen zu können. Der saß da in seiner Übersetzer-Kapsel immer so. Ich konnte das gar nicht fassen. Fand ich sehr lustig. Muss mir dringend mal anhören, was der da draus gemacht hat.
Genau, falls irgendjemand noch nicht begriffen hat, von wem wir sprechen. Wir sprechen von dem Ralf Kaspers, bekannt auch aus Wissen macht A.
Der Sendung mit der Maus.
Genau, und das auch später dann. Und Quarks und Kaspers, was ich dann etwas ungelenkt benannte Sendungen finde.
Minimal.
Wann haben die ihre Sendung?
Wer?
Die beiden Kaspers.
Keine Ahnung, ich glaube, Wissen macht A kommt wöchentlich, stimmt das?
Nee, jetzt hier auf.
Jetzt hat er schon wieder abgehauen.
Nee, der hat einen Vortrag gehabt, den hat er gestern gehalten und der musste dann auch leider wieder zurück, aber man merkte ihm an, dass er eine Träne im Knopfloch hatte, weil er dann wohl geschneit hat, wo er denn eigentlich ist und meinte, hätte man ja auch mal Urlaub nehmen können. Hat er aber nicht. Ja, nichtsdestotrotz war er da, guter einen Vortrag. Ich weiß nicht, wie findet ihr denn eigentlich so das Camp da? So, ist das irgendwie?
Nicht so geil oder was?
Wir haben ja dieses Mal ein Publikum, wir machen das mal so wie auf einem ITF-Meeting, wenn wir jetzt so Sachen fragen, dann hummt ihr mal bitte so.
Habt ihr die Frage verstanden?
Die Licht, habt ihr die Frage verstanden? Da geht noch was, wir benutzen das nachher noch mal.
Jetzt hast du mich rausgebracht. Entschuldigung.
Deko hattest du gerade in den Mundwinkeln.
Ob sie dir toll fanden.
Man kann ja überhaupt auch erst mal fragen, ob es dir toll ist, aber sollen wir erstmal auf die Details gehen oder wollen wir erstmal von oben? Ich weiß nicht. Hast du vielleicht irgendwas beizutragen?
Nein. Ich hab ja schon beigetragen.
Du hast auch diese Veranstaltung eröffnet. Ich muss zugeben, dass ich das noch nicht habe nachschauen können und habe da noch geschlafen.
Ein Fragmaß. Ich gebe es zumindest zu.
Da hättest du zum Beispiel gelernt, dass diese Veranstaltung dreimal mehr Wasser, so viel Wasser verbraucht wie alle drei Dörfer in den fünf Tagen da sozusagen.
Hast du noch weitere Weisheiten von dir gegeben?
Ja genau, die haben nur fünf Einwohner. Ja, nee, das war auf jeden Fall sehr schön. Aber jetzt hab ich auch schon wieder alles vergessen.
Vorbereitet?
Wir haben ganz viel erklärt natürlich von diesem tollen Programm hier. Unter anderem dem Party Night Train. Wer von euch hat denn schon den Party Night Train besucht? Nee, Summen, Summen. Noch nicht so viele, noch nicht so viele.
Nein, das ist nicht so begeistert. Also falls ihr es noch nicht gemerkt habt, es gibt da immer abends so einen Party Night Train, also diese kleine Bimmelbahn, diese alte Ziegeleitbahn, die kurft da durch die Gegend. Und es gibt einen Wagen mit einer Bar, es gibt einen Wagen mit einem Bällebad.
Wo die Leute schon wieder Elektronik drin verloren haben. Plastisch, wie sich das gehört. Hab mich noch gefreut in Hamburg, wo ich jetzt letztes Jahr mal war. Und da haben dann Leute stolz berichtet, sie hätten ja ihr iPhone im Bällebad verloren. Und haben dann danach gesucht. Das migrierte dann nach unten irgendwie, weil es ja schwerer ist als die Bälle. Und dann haben sie ein Weile gewühlt und haben ein iPhone gefunden. Und jetzt spielen sie das hier wohl mit den Badges.
Ja, wir haben in der Eröffnung zur Veranstaltung auch ganz viel von was ist Camp erzählt eigentlich auch. Weil das ja doch ein bisschen anders. Und jetzt, wo ich vier Jahre wieder vergehen hab lassen, seit dem letzten Camp, ist es auch wieder so, dass ich auf dem Camp bin und denke, es ist schon noch mal ganz anders als Kongressor. Diese ganze Grundschwingung sozusagen von dieser Veranstaltung ist einfach so tiefenentspannt und staubig. Und brummig, ja, aber es ist doch irgendwie immer wieder gut.
Wer hat schon mehr als drei Vorträge gesehen?
Ah, sehr gut.
Mehr als fünf?
Hm, war nicht so viel, ne?
Hum now if you've seen them all.
Aber hum ist doch eigentlich nur so ja nein oder nicht?
Nee, nee, die fragen dann so, wollen wir das so oder so machen? Und dann sagen sie jetzt für Variante A, hum now und dann für Variante B, hum now.
Okay, ich hoffe, dass unser Publikumsmikrofon hier das auch ansprechen kann.
Ja, schmeißt das noch runter.
Aber ich muss sagen, ich hab bisher auf keinem Camp Vorträge gesehen und auf diesem hab ich tatsächlich schon mehr als fünf gesehen.
Ich find das auch super gelöst. Also ich denke, dass diese großen Zelte deutlich besser sind als die Bunker das letzte Mal. Super schöne Zelte, auch sehr dunkel, wenn sie sein wollen. Also da kann man richtig was...
Ist der warm?
Warm, ja gut.
Die Saunazelte.
Na ja gut, das bringt das halt so mittig.
Bunker doch cooler am warsten.
Man kann auch schön Aufkleber unter die Sitze kleben.
Andere Leute, andere Hobbys.
Das war Tims Idee, nicht meine.
Wir hatten so Logbuch-Netzpolitik-Aufkleber. Die sind lustig.
Ne, wie war's?
Also wenn du einen haben willst... Ja, es gibt da so sieben Motive und die Hälfte dürfte noch irgendwie unter den hinteren Sitzen, da kann man auch welche finden. Ansonsten sind die Aufkleber leider schnell weg.
Aber jetzt aber nochmal eine kurze Umfrage. Also Tim war bestimmt auf allen Camps. Dennis warst du auch auf allen Camps?
Die in Deutschland.
Wie viel gab's denn davon? Also die CCC 5.
Du meinst jetzt, das ist das Fünfte?
Das ist das Fünfte. 99 war das Erste, ne? Ich hab das Erste knapp verpasst, hab mich gerade erst im CCC gelandet und dann war Camp schon vorbei. Und Clemens?
Ich hab besucht, wie hieß denn das Ding, das welches waren? Das ist in der Altlandsberg, das ist schon ein bisschen länger her, das war der zweite oder der erste oder so.
Der erste und zweite war in Altlandsberg, dritte und vierte war in Finofort.
Ich hab mich besucht, Finofort hab ich auch einmal besucht und das ist jetzt das, wo ich jetzt hier mal so bin.
Ah, also ein Frischling quasi.
Jetzt bist du Dauergast und nicht nur Tagesgast.
Kann man mal machen.
Ist das so, wie du es dir hier vorgestellt hast?
Ich muss jetzt eigentlich nur den Deckel da ploppen lassen, dann ist alles klar.
Also außer Monsieur Brüm Brüm.
Er hat nämlich sein Zelt genau erst dann...
Ja, ich kam da an, es war schon dunkel, da war noch eine Stelle und dann hab ich das Zelt dahingestellt und dann war's halt.
Direkt mit dem Generator, ja?
Schräg gegenüber war der Generator und dazwischen ein Bahngleis.
Aber war dir nicht an, als du dein Zelt aufgebaut hast? War der Generator nicht an?
Ja, aber ich war zu fertig, um zu merken, dass das vielleicht ein Problem sein könnte.
Als ich mein Zelt aufgebaut hab, da war der noch nicht da.
Ja, so ging's das ja auch.
65 Dezibel am Zelt, voll geil.
Ja, okay und abgesehen von Monsieur Brüm Brüm.
Ja komm, jetzt lass jetzt nicht aus der Nase ziehen.
Ja, was soll ich denn sagen?
Ja, was weiß ich? Geil!
Jetzt in den höchsten Tönen loben.
Oder irgendwie, naja, Campinger halt so.
Ja, kann man nicht meckern.
Das höchste Lob eines Berliners. Genau.
Also andere Erstlinge, die ich schon gehört hab, haben zum Beispiel bemerkt, so Dinge wie, ist jetzt nicht wie auf einem Musikfestival, wo sich da die Massen so hin und her schieben und es total unentspannt ist, überhaupt von A nach B zu kommen, sondern es wurde zum Beispiel die generelle Entspanntheit gelobt, das Essen wurde schon gelobt, die ganzen Roboterinstallationen und irgendwie dieses Camp wird auch gekocht, wie die Weltmeister. Also in allen Ecken und Enden wird hier, werden Fressfeste veranstaltet.
Es ist interessant, dass mittlerweile Essen auch so eine Sportart im Hackbereich geworden ist. Das war ja früher nicht so.
Ich will noch mal auf diese arschloffreie Zone hinkommen, weil es kommt wirklich gut durch, dass das alles sehr kooperativ ist. Die Leute arbeiten halt zusammen, keiner arscht den anderen an, jeder gibt jedem was ab. Das finde ich schon sehr cool, muss ich wirklich sagen. Es ist ja mal alles so kein Problem. Hast du mal einen Strom? Nee, aber da hinten. Warte mal, ich hole dir den mal rüber. Hier hast du noch mal da ein Netz und so weiter.
Oder wenn du nachts dein Laptop vorm Zelt liegen lässt, dann kommt es den nächsten Morgen raus und ist nicht weg. Sondern hat jemand Strom gerannt und macht damit es nicht ausgeht.
Aber irgendwie so ein komischer Trend dieses Camps ist irgendwie diese ABC-Rettungsfolien auf den Zelten. Ich war ja gerade im Segelurlaub und so hab mich an dieses Meeresrauschen gewöhnt. Jetzt, wenn ich nachts im Zelt liege, höre ich diese Folien knistern. Ich hab mir ja auch eingeredet, es wäre jetzt Wellenrauschen, das kommt so in etwa in die Richtung.
Ich glaube, seit Norden ist die Aluhut-Fraktion wieder obenauf.
Also angefangen haben wir damit, glaube ich, auf dem zweiten Camp und war halt für die Datenklos. Aber ich glaube, wir haben es falsch rumgemacht. Wir haben irgendwie Gold nach außen.
Es gibt da keinen wirklich falsch rum. Jemand hat es letztens gegoogelt, Wikipedia. Und eine Seite ist nur 4% besser als die andere. Deswegen ist es eigentlich egal.
Verstehe. Ich glaube, wir hatten alle den Gold. Nachdem die Idee des Datenklos auf dem ersten Camp geboren wurde und man festgestellt hat, dass da auch Temperaturen entstehen und man damit auch mal ein bisschen klarkommen muss. Das waren ja noch so Tisch-Switches, die wir damals zum Einsatz gebracht haben.
Und dann habt ihr Daten-Clo-Edition draus gemacht, oder wie?
Beim nächsten Camp haben wir das dann richtig gemacht. Beim ersten Mal stand da nur ein kaputtes rum und wir haben das mal benutzt, weil es eh nicht benutzt wurde.
Nein, nein, wir haben die explizit...
Und nicht beim ersten.
Doch, doch. Ich schreibe mir mit Papillon immer noch darum, wer es jetzt erfunden hat, aber wir haben auf jeden Fall überlegt, wo tun wir diese Netzwerk-Technik rein und dann sind wir halt auf diese lustige Idee gekommen, dass wir uns halt einfach kaputte Dixies mieten, weil die waren halt super billig.
Das war aber erst beim zweiten.
Nein.
Ja, ich wisse doch. Ich hab da Netz gemacht auf dem ersten noch.
Ja, da hatten wir Datenklos.
Nein, da war nur eins, was kaputt war. Das haben wir benutzt und das fanden wir so gut, dass wir beim zweiten dann gesagt haben, Jungs, hier bringen uns die kaputten Dixies.
Was, beim ersten?
Noch nicht.
Doch. Am ersten hatten wir auch Datenklos. Naja, wie auch immer. Tatsache ist, mit der Goldfolie war sozusagen eine Idee dafür und jetzt greift es halt so über.
Aber dieses Camp ist halt extrem, finde ich. Sieht irgendwie krass aus. Ach, tatsächlich, auch das noch.
Wurden von führenden Wikis entfohlen.
Von führenden Wikis. Hacker, die Doms gekauft haben, haben auch kiloweise ABC-Folie gekauft. Das scheint irgendwie der zweite Trend zu sein, auf jeden Fall, dieses Camp.
Wo ist denn dein Zelt? Unter dem Baum, im Schatten?
Hinter einer Hecke.
Brauchst also keine Folie.
Ich meine, früher war das ja auch so, war das ja so ein Witz, Hacker aus dem Keller in der Sonne und so. Aber war ja schon so, dass jetzt viele nicht unbedingt die Erfahrung hatten, so ein Zelt aufzubauen. Das war dann schon wieder drin, aber es waren ja alle in kleinen Zelten. Und dann im zweiten Camp ging das dann los, mit so, na jetzt bauen wir mal was Größeres. Und dann kam ja auch so die Camping-Industrie selbst noch so ein bisschen in Wallungen, und diese großen Zelte wurden dann so gemacht. Aber jetzt muss man ja schon im Prinzip seinen eigenen 3D-gedruckten Dom mitbringen, wenn man überhaupt noch irgendwie Bestand haben will.
Ja, da kann ich gleich noch einen Kollegen featuren. Der hat ja hier quasi, den hab ich versucht, schon zum letzten Camp zu bringen. Da hat er so gesagt, na ja, mal sehen, gucken. Dann irgendwie ist er natürlich nicht gekommen, hab ich ihm hinterher die Fotos und Videos gezeigt. Und er so, ja, wann ist das nächste Camp? Vier Jahre. Und jetzt hat er sich aber vorbereitet, diesmal hat er sich nicht lange bitten lassen, hat sich einen eigenen Dom ausgedacht, also eigentlich einen halben 20-seitigen Würfel, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung hab, mit gleichseitigen Dreiecken. Und der Clou ist halt, dass er die Verbinder aus einem dicken Gartenschlauch gemacht hat, also er hat sozusagen Kreuze aus Gartenschlauch zusammengeschraubt. Nein, einfach nur wirklich stumpf der Gummischlauch und dann Rundhölzer aus dem Baumarkt bestellt und hat sich dann da draus diesen Dom zusammengesteckt. Also super Low-Tech-Materialkosten unter zweieinhalb Euro. Als wir den aufgebaut haben, da war auch wieder dieses arschlochfreie Zonen, da kamen auch gleich ganz viele Leute und haben sich auch gleich inspiriert gezeigt. So, ah, so kann man das auch machen. Und dann hat er gleich hier so seinen ersten Hack abgeliefert mit. Und wenn ihr das mal beobachten wollt, das steht da hinten am See. Die Plane ist noch ein bisschen schwierig gerade. Es gibt sozusagen Call for Proposals, wie man das jetzt noch bedecken könnte. Und er hat den Twitter-Account Starfish Tent, wo sozusagen er gerne den Bauplan teilen will oder die Materialliste und aber auch gerne wissen will, wie er es bespannen kann. Könnt ihr mal euch angucken. Und das ist ganz witzig, weil die Rundhölzer, wenn man die anfasst, die sind super wabbelig. Aber wenn du an so einem Kreuz mal drückst, bewegt sich genau nix.
Also echt cooler Hack.
Apropos Shownotes. Haben wir denn eigentlich Shownoten hier? Und wenn ja, sind die ja vielleicht sogar live. Gibt es hier Shownoten? Ja, da hinten. Vielen Dank übrigens für eure Arbeit.
Übrigens noch ein kleiner Tipp zum Camp. Wer von euch ist denn das erste Mal da? Jetzt bitte laut summmen.
Wer ist nicht das erste Mal da?
Jetzt natürlich die Preisfrage. Wer von euch hat sich von der Freak Show inspirieren lassen, zum Camp zu kommen? Wenn ihr gelogen habt, jetzt nicht summen. Kleiner Aufmerksamkeit am Rande, aber für die die, es gibt ja anscheinend viele. Ich hab auch gelernt, weil ich jetzt ja schon ein paar mal da bin, hab ich das irgendwie verpasst, diese Erstlingseinführung. Es gibt irgendwie die 5-2-1-Regel, war das richtig Fiona?
5-1.
5 mal, nee 5 Stunden schlafen, 2 mal essen und einmal duschen am Tag, dann hat man...
2 von den Dingen sind für dich und eine Sache ist für alle anderen.
Auch für dich, auch für dich. Aber habt ihr von dieser Regel schon gehört? Habt ihr die Regel schon befolgt, ohne sie zu hören? Okay, okay, nicht so schlecht, nicht so schlecht.
Also am ersten Tag hab ich es nicht geschafft. Sondern das die 5 Stunden schlafen, überhaupt nicht.
Neben Mr. Brum...
Ja, 2 Stunden war es.
Badenstadt duschen ist natürlich auch eine gute Ausrede, genau.
Ja genau, das war auch ein Aufruf aus der Öffnungsveranstaltung, dass man sich doch eben dieses Wasserverbrauch mal bewusst sein soll und nicht unendlich duschen soll. Aber ich hab gehört und auch aus Augenzeugenberichten eigener Art, dass das Wasser relativ kalt ist. Das ist vielleicht auch ein Feature, um den Wasserverbrauch klein zu halten. Heißduscher, Kaltduscher und Heißduscher. Na gut, Wassersparen. Ich hab Feedback hier irgendwie.
Der Hucke hätte gerne noch zwei eiskalte Afrikola. Zwei.
Das stimmt. Und, haben wir noch Themen? Achso, ich hab noch eine tolle Empfehlung. Auch aus gewöhnlich gut informierten Kreisen. Es gibt ja hier auch so Partyprogramm. Und heute soll bei der Mainstage ein gutes Partyprogramm sein, weil einer der Musikkonnoisseure hat sich extra in die Künstlerbetreuungsschicht eintragen lassen, damit er heute den ganzen Abend und die ganze Nacht das Programm da begutachten kann. Und wenn der das macht, ist das vielleicht wirklich gut. Also, das könnt ihr heute auch nochmal auschecken. Nee, die Mainstage ist da ganz hinten, wo die Lok Bar ist, also so eine Bar zwischen zwei Dampfloks oder so.
Also letzte Nacht war Party hier bis wie viel? Vier, fünf Uhr morgens?
Hier im Bear.
Und im anderen Mainstage wie lange?
Weiß ich nicht, gestern hab ich geschlafen, ich hab Antihistamine genommen und die haben mich direkt bang!
Muss die anderen nehmen.
Ich meine, wir haben ja ungefähr so, weiß nicht, 4500 Leute hier auf dem Acker. Das klingt ja irgendwie viel, aber interessanter, keiner wusste so richtig, wie sich das auf dieses Gelände wirklich ausüben wird. Aber ehrlich gesagt, für meinen Geschmack könnten auch noch mehr reinpassen.
Die sind halt alle in ihren Zelten am Hacken.
Passt über nicht.
Doch, auch da. Können sie ja sein, aber nochmal zu tausend.
Von der Fläche her ginge das bestimmt, aber da muss man, wie gesagt, an der Infrastruktur noch mal ein bisschen was basteln.
Ja klar, im Wesentlichen wäre das so...
Denk an das Schwarzwasser.
Tagesgästemäßig, das ist ja so im Vorfeld nicht immer so richtig klar gewesen, wie das jetzt laufen soll. Das Fass will ich jetzt eigentlich auch gar nicht aufmachen, aber es ist halt wie immer das erste Mal ist Beta-Version. Das war in Alt Landsberg so, das war in Vienovoz so und naja, keine Ahnung. Ich bin ehrlich gesagt davon ausgegangen, dass dieses Gelände es irgendwie nicht schafft, auch ein zweites Mal ein Camp aufzunehmen, weil man irgendwie an zu vielen Ecken anstößt. Aber ich muss sagen, es ist echt super geschmeidig. Also der Family-Bereich, der ist einfach traumhaft. Das Platzangebot ist eigentlich super.
Jetzt gar nicht mehr zurück nach Berlin, ne?
So viele Bäume und Licht und so.
Nicht in der Mad Max, eher da drüben.
Wir haben noch nicht über die Deko geredet.
Kriegt alle Kinder, dann könnt ihr da auch hin.
Ich finde die Deko, finde ich fantastisch. Also nicht nur, was jetzt überhaupt alle Leute so mitbringen, sondern einfach die Lichtgestaltung auf diesem Camp.
Auch die alten Sachen vom Ziegeleih-Park, zum Beispiel die alten, hinter dem Hügel da, diese alten Bagage, Schornsteine, alle Gebäude und so weiter.
Alles sehr umfangreich und der Brüller ist natürlich, wer das von euch noch nicht gemacht hat, lauft mal heute Nacht irgendwie auf diesen Aussichtsturm drauf. Das brillt echt enorm. Also wenn man sich da das Camp von oben anschaut, da kriegt man echt zu viel.
Ist das eigentlich wieder eine spezielle Arbeitsgruppe? Oh ja, die Disco Kugel im Wald mit den Hängematten drunter.
Genau.
Muss man aber aufpassen, da gucken so Stahlstreben raus, so vier Stück noch von irgendeinem alten Gebäude. Wenn man nachts mal nicht sieht, da kann man böse gegenlaufen. Hat schon der erste Eier gemacht, war nicht so schön.
Genau, vielleicht kurz der Hinweis. Ich hab mich mal mit dem Zert irgendwie im Vorfeld unterhalten und meinte so, ja, was sind denn eigentlich so die Hauptursachen für die Fälle, die ihr hier so zu behandeln habt? Meinte sie so, ja, Dumm halt.
Bei der Freak Show hört ihr es zuerst.
Sie konnte das auch mit einigen lustigen Anekdoten belegen, wo man ganz schön viel facial palmieren muss, aber seht euch vor, es gibt eine Strichliste im Zert, linker Fuß oder rechter Fuß.
Bei uns gar nicht so weit.
Was?
Heringe?
Ja, Heringe und Schienen, das ist natürlich hier.
Gar nicht so weit weg von Muckelhausen hat heute einer ausprobiert, was passiert, wenn man eine Dose Ravioli auf den Herd stellt und sie nicht aufmacht. Und derselbe Typ hat dann auch kurz danach ausprobiert, was passiert, wenn man sein Propangas-Dink auslaufen lässt, während es in Betrieb ist.
Waren das kontrollierte Experimente?
Ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, er fiel in diese Kategorie rein, die da der erste Grund, der erste Hauptgrund.
Aber das mit den Fußfallen ist auch schwierig, weil ich mein Zelt schlauerweise mitten in der Nacht aufbaute und dachte, der sieht ja schön nach Wiese aus. Und so steckst du mal rein, 2 cm später, stein. Dann hab ich natürlich auch ein Hammer geliehen bekommen, glücklicherweise, und hab das mit brutals möglicher Kraft die Hälfte der Heringe verbogen. Ich glaube, viele Leute haben einfach das Problem, dass die Heringe noch zur Hälfte rausgucken und dann nachts so... Wer von euch hat denn keine Kopflampe mitgenommen?
Nächstes Mal. Das war Anfänger. Ich find den nicht cool. Gehört immer geblendet, werden die Leute dann an.
Aber es ist immer so, man haut sich einfach am Kopf und denkt sich so, das hast du dir in den letzten zehn Events immer wieder gesagt, nächste Mal nimmst du das mit. Zum Beispiel Wassersprühflasche.
Gibst du da hinten so eine Dauerinstallation, damit die LKW nicht so viel Staub macht?
Ja, und vor allem die Deluxe-Variante ist der Rucksack-Gardener-Kompressor, wo man immer so... Dann kannst du immer so richtig schön mit so...
Das ist die geile Idee, ich hab so ein Ding in meinem Land. Das hol ich morgen.
Ja, hol mal, da machst du richtig Freude. Morgen soll es ja regnen, dann wird das nicht mehr so geil. Aber die letzten Tage ist...
Da war zwar ein bisschen Dünger drin, aber scheiß drauf, dann wachsen die Hacker.
Eine geile Installation war auch hinten bei den Österreichern. Da steht ja so ein Dome, der auch mit so einer ABC-Polie umwickelt ist. Und da haben die oben einfach so einen Standventilatorcase quasi noch in den Dome reinpusten lassen. Das fand ich auch ganz schick. Haben sie aber im Regen auch draußen lassen und weiß nicht, ob der Ventilator das noch mitgemacht hat. Aber Sprühflaschen, super. Da gibt's auch ein fettes Gebläse irgendwo da drüben mit so Wasserinfusionen.
Ein Unterschied zu den alten Camps ist ja noch, dass bei den ersten Camps, ja ja... Feedback... .dass wir da nur die Hauptzelte hatten. Und jetzt haben wir hier ganz viele Villages. Und das ist vielmehr selbst organisiert hier, so wie die Sea-Base, wo es auch lecker lecker Essen gibt. Heute Kartoffeln mit Senfeiern. Hab ich verpasst?
Scheiße.
Und das BER hat gestern schon ziemlich gut gerockt. Das gab's früher nicht so.
Ja, und hier beim Millie-Base, da wird ja auch fleißig gekocht. Da wird gebacken, da gibt's irgendwie...
Leute, die haben hier wohl einen Ofen aufgebaut.
Der Typ ist extra mit einem Lastwagen voll Lehm angekarrt. Und dann haben die den da gemauert und dann mit Lehm aufgebaut. An dem ersten Tag halt das ganze Stroh, mit dem sie sozusagen erstmal in die Trage Konstruktion gebaut haben, das Heu dann so ausgebrannt.
Die haben Lehm zum Ziegeleihof hier gefahren. Ist ja wie Eulen nach Athen.
Aber einfach coole Sache und überhaupt sind extrem viele solche Installationen, Ideen und Gefährte auch. Habt ihr dieses Mate-Elektro-Karre irgendwie gesehen? Aus drei oder vier Club-Mate-Kisten, die das irgendwie halten. Und so wie so ein kleiner E-Traktor, da sitzt er halt so drauf, fühlt einfach nur auf vier Club-Mate-Kisten, die durch die Gegend fahren. Total großartig. Dann gibt's irgendwie da vorne, welches Village war das nochmal? Ihr wisst sicherlich gleich, was ich meine. Ich glaub ICMP, da wo die, diese Hell-Nach-, diese Hell-Computer-Nachbau ist. Also diese Module irgendwie aus 2001. Ja, nicht die Stelle, sondern mehr so dieses my mind is going, also wo er dann sozusagen so an diesen, diesen, diesen Plexiglas-Teil, genau.
Den hab ich noch nicht gesehen.
Was ich auch schön finde, ist, dass die Nerds natürlich stehen ja schon immer auf Eisenbahnen. Das ist natürlich auch das geile Gelände dafür. Die sind hier schon am Tag, die sind hier schon am Tag Minus zwei oder sowas, glaube ich. Sind die schon mit der ersten selbstgebauten Dresine hier durch die Gegend gefahren auf den Schienen. Mit irgendein, keine Ahnung, irgendein Motor dran aus dem Rollstuhl oder so. Ich weiß noch nicht. Aber sehr geil irgendwie. Wenn du eh schon so nerdy Umgebung hast und dennoch Schienen legst.
Jetzt wo du es sagst, bin ich fast überrascht, dass es nicht mehr davon gibt, dass es eigentlich die geile Hacksportidee ist.
Ich hab die ein paar Mal hier mit dem Ding hier hoch und runter.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die Spurweite vorher kommuniziert worden ist. Die Befahrbarkeit dieses Systems.
Okay, die Spurweite kommuniziert.
Das sind dann sicherlich die Dinge, die dann bei einer Wiederholung absolut... Ich mein, das ist irgendwie auch noch so ein bisschen merkwürdig geregelt. Man muss hier auf jeden Fall mal eine Flatrate einführen für diese ganze Sprachung oder ein anderes System mit Ticket kaufen.
Das ist so geil, da hinten am Family Village, da gibt es so eine Stelle, wo die immer langsamer werden. Du kannst dann sich in Ruhe hinsetzen, was essen und einfach nur darauf warten, dass die Bahn kommt. Dann schleichen sich ein paar Nerds ganz unauffällig an, als würden sie eigentlich nur darauf warten, dass die Bahn vorbeifährt. Dann würden sie auch schon gleich weitergehen und dann gucken sie. Dann setzen sie sich so drauf. Mittlerweile hat es der Lokführer schon drauf und hat schon den Finger an der Hupe, wenn er in diese Kurve reinfährt. In dem Moment, wo die Nerds einen kleinen Move machen, war er so...
Ach, wie da stand es zwecklos.
Einfach draufsetzen, genau. Aber der Typ, der den Party Train fällt, der hat immer Spaß, der hat immer ein Lächeln auf den Lippen.
Vorhin ist das Ding ja entgleist. Habt ihr das mitbekommen?
Mehrfach.
Mehrfach sogar? Das war direkt vor dem Sendezentrum, ist das Ding auf einmal entgleist. Dann kamen gleich so zehn Nerds an, haben das Ding einfach wieder in die Schienen reingehoben.
Oder einen Gabelstapel.
Und abends ging's wieder mit Bälle Bart und volles Programm. Da kann ja auch nicht sein, dass die Cocktailbar hier irgendwie strandet. Ich frage mich...
Vorm Sendezentrum darf die stranden.
Das ist eigentlich eine gute Idee, warum haben die wieder reingehoben?
Vielleicht sollten wir den Stein mal wieder...
Warum entgleist die da, Tim? Warum entgleist die da?
Das ist eine gute Frage, das liegt bestimmt am Generator.
Ich muss mir mal eine Zigarette anzünden, die Mücken kommen.
Habt ihr denn auch andere interessante Installationen angetroffen? Natürlich ist das Camp voll davon, aber wir können ja auch mal darüber reden.
Also hast du zum Beispiel einen Caray-Gate-3D-Drucker gesehen, das fand ich schon mal sehr interessant. Das war mitten in einem Zelt. Du guckst da durch so ein kleines Zelt, mitten in Mad Max Country, denkst an nichts Böses, guckst durch den Schlitz, da wirklich so ein 3D-Drucker. So.
Da kannst du so nochmal ein Portemonnaie drucken.
Ja, mindestens einen Kubikmeter, wenn nicht zwei.
Mich kann man drucken.
Schöne, irgendwie auch so eine wiederkehrende Installation ist ja der Pancake-Robot. Auch von den Wienern da.
Ja, ist ja schon ein bisschen älter.
Ja, genau, der ist aber legendär, weil das Witzige war. Ich hab mir den an Tag 0, bin ich da vorbei, und dann haben wir auch gerade eine Vorführung gesehen und der Typ dann auch so am Rumschrauben und so und noch erklären, da irgendwie der Druck und irgendwas. Und dann später treffe ich irgendwie auf Fiona und die erzählen, so PenCank-Roboter ist auch schon da und dann meint sie so, ja, ja, der ist immer am Schrauben und hat irgendwie also genau wiedergegeben quasi, wie der Typ da immer an seinem PenCank-Roboter, auch nach Jahren immer noch nicht zufrieden ist und der Scheibenwischer und alles und irgendwie muss da nochmal. Wobei die Installation an sich nach wie vor cool ist.
Ja, stimmt.
Ja, aber immer noch eine Schraube locker, ne? Ja, irgendwie zum Testen sind wir nicht mehr gekommen, leider.
Du bist ja hier auch so ein bisschen in Orga involviert oder bekannt.
Ich?
Wo kriegt man so ein riesen Zelt her? Wietet die 25.01? Das kriegst du jetzt nicht beim üblichen Hochzeitszelte von dir, oder?
Ist das so ein kleines?
Ist das ein pleitegegangenes Zirkus-Zelt?
Es ist schon ganz schön bemerkenswert, was man so an Zelten alles mieten kann, wenn man es bezahlen kann. Ich kann dir aber jetzt gerade nicht genau sagen, was die Quelle ist.
Aber du meinst jetzt die großen Vortragszelte? Die standen auch vorher noch auf einem anderen Festival, bis Sonntag. Sonne, Mond und Sterne, glaube ich. Also die wandern auch so rum. Nein, es gibt verschiedene Firmen tatsächlich. Und die Orga ist auch, glaube ich, nicht besonders gut, auf die Zeltbauer zu sprechen, habe ich gehört, weil da gab es wohl einige Fnords.
Es gab eine Zögerung. Das ist deutlich später aufgebaut, alles gewesen, aber egal.
Also unsere Eröffnungsveranstaltung, da war kurz vorher wurde der Boden da reingedübelt und dann war eine Viertelstunde später war das Zelt erst fertig. Ja, also bis auf die letzte Sekunde.
Das nennt man Just in Time und ist angeblich ein total zukunftsfähiges Konzept der Wirtschaft. Das kann so falsch sein.
Der ganz normale Wahnsinn.
Haben wir denn noch andere... Ich hätt's mir mal aufschreiben sollen. Der Fernsehturm von der Seabase ist großartig. Ja, der Fernsehturm ist super.
Der dreht sich sogar.
Ich behaupte ja steif und fest, dass da oben in der Antenne auch was drin ist, was sendet. Scheiß egal, ob das WLAN ist, aber niemand baut doch auf so einem Camp wie hier eine Antenne dieser Art und dieser Größe ohne Dativ was sendet. Kann das hier mal irgendjemand bestätigen? Oder wie ist Seabase da?
Wollt ihr das mal bestätigen oder dementieren?
Leute, die wissen, dass da was drin sendet, bitte hum now.
Okay, einer weiß es.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein Geheimnis.
Ich dachte aber auch so, jetzt wo jetzt Gewitter angesagt wird, und die ganzen Amateurfunker, die ja da auch wieder ihr ganzes Equipmentmeter hoch aufgetürmt haben, ob man eigentlich an denen erkennen könnte, ob es wirklich ernst wird mit dem Gewitter, wenn die anfangen ihre Antennen einzuziehen.
Habt ihr eigentlich die Rakete gesehen?
Ja, natürlich.
Ist euch was aufgefallen?
Die hatte zu viel Party gestern, die Rakete.
Was?
Die hatte zu viel Party gestern.
Wieso?
Weil sie so viel Glitzer hat. Leute, die von dicken Partys kommen, haben immer noch Glitzer am nächsten Tag.
Jaja, das freut mich natürlich besonders, dass das Ding jetzt zwölf Jahre nach ihrer ursprünglichen Fertigstellung mal überarbeitet worden ist. Und Hassow, der die ja gebaut hat, hat die jetzt sozusagen auch überarbeitet, und die war ja schon total reudig runtergerockt.
Die stand jetzt zwölf Jahre im Freien.
Und tausend Transporter und Dellen hier und da. Es war einfach ein Elend. Und das Ding wär uns irgendwie so langsam mal dahin geschimmelt. Also gab's den Beschluss, dass ich da was ändern muss. Und dann sind wir halt da in die Folgen gegangen. Und Hassow hat irgendwie mit seiner Truppe da ein Auto Metallic-Lack in mehreren Lagen mit Goldglitzer irgendwie noch draufgemacht. Das muss eine super krasse Aktion gewesen sein. Also erstmal so sauber machen, polieren, alle Sachen wegspachteln, glatt, dann Grundierung, dann nochmal Lack, dann nochmal Lack und nochmal Lack und dann irgendwie Glitzer und nochmal Lack und dann irgendwie alles nochmal poliert bis zum Exzess. Und ich muss sagen, ich hab das Ding zuerst nachts gesehen mit Bestrahlung. Und da sah das irgendwie schon total schick aus. Ich dachte mir so, boah, cool, hat sich ja voll gelohnt. Und danach hab ich es erst in der Sonne gesehen, da hab ich fast nach hinten umgekippt, wie irre das in der Sonne kommt.
Morgen nach dem Regen sieht die nochmal geil aus.
Weil sie dann geputzt ist oder was?
Ja, nee, so mit Wasserperlen drauf.
Achso, naja gut. Es hat ja jetzt letzte Nacht wohl auch kurz geregnet.
Aber die Flamme ist jetzt ja auch sozusagen eingezeichnet. Daran habe ich es eigentlich von der Ferne erkannt. Gab es die schon beim ersten Camp?
Kleiner Test, wer weiß, wie die Rakete heißt?
Ja, sie wissen, wie die Rakete heißt.
Die passen besser auf als du.
Sehr schön. So, dann gab es Radio. Radio, die längste Schlange auf dem Camp. Wir haben ja Freak Show-Berichtete. Wir halten das hier mal kurz in die Menge, wer es noch nicht gesehen hat. Aber ihr habt ja wahrscheinlich alle einen schon abgeholt. Natürlich. Ein unglaublich klobiges, dickes Teil. Also man läuft so ein bisschen rum wie so ein Hip-Hopper. Display drauf, aller möglicher. Antenne, Pipapo, USB. Und ich weiß nicht, habt ihr schon von ersten Applikationen gehört, die hier schon entwickelt wurden?
Radio-Applikationen? Ich hab nur Hipster gesehen, die natürlich gleich wieder alle voll mit LED gepimpt hatten und so. Da bräuchte ich übrigens noch mal ein Pro-Tipp, wer mir da noch mal was twitteren kann, ich bräuchte mal so ein Gehäuse. Ja, es gibt hier jede Menge Zelte, das ist das Problem.
Bei den Münchnern gibt es jetzt auch so ein Plexiglas-Gehäuse dafür.
Bei den Münchnern.
Ja, bei den Münchnern.
Und das Special-Feature ist, hier vorne ist gleich so ein Maker-Wagen mit 3D-Druckern und Laser-Cuttern und da kannst du dir auch einen Case lasern.
Der mit 3D-Dingern.
Ja und der hat auch irgendwie einen Lasercutter und da stand irgendwie ein Schild dran. Hier kannst du dir auch dein Radio-Batch-Case lasern.
Zwischen... Zwischen... Zwischen Seabase und München, da gibt's die noch. Also es gibt auch noch welche, ja?
Bring Plexiglas, er macht Laser.
Sehr gut.
Also da gibt's auf jeden Fall eine Option. Ja, also zu den lustigeren Ideen, die ich gehört habe, war hier, es gibt hier so Tore, die werden so per Funk geöffnet.
Also eine schöne Anwendung, von der ich gehört habe, dass Leute sie probieren wollten oder so was, ist, dass sie da mal was mit Zigbee spielen wollten und damit diese ganzen LED-Anzeigen, die nur jeder trop zu hängen hat, mit der Fernsteuerung, weißt du, wo du denn die Farbe setzen kannst, dass du da so ein Programm drauf machst, dass du einfach durch die Gegend läufst, was immer alle Dinge auf rot stellt und überall da, wo du langläufst, wird alles rot. Sowas könnte ich mir auch ganz gut vorstellen.
Das ist auch nicht schlecht. Ich dachte mir, was so richtig advanced wäre, wenn man...
Mesh-Netzwerk macht.
Ja, genau, das eh. Die Frage ist nur, was macht man mit dem Mesh-Netzwerk? Wenn man jetzt so rumläuft und sich sowieso vermesht mit allen, könnten ja im Prinzip alle Geräte die Daten über alle anderen Geräte auch anliefern, sodass man quasi über alle anderen Teilnehmer dieses Mesh-Netzwerk auch permanent eine Triangulation machen kann. Sodass man eigentlich dadurch so eine komplette Karte werbefindet, wo durchziehen könnte.
Super Idee.
Herr Uhl, darf ich ihm mal die Maske abbreiten?
Mal ehrlich, ich benutze ja hier Find My Friends auf meinem iPhone und das ist einfach der Brüller. Ich hab jetzt irgendwie hier so 20 Leute drauf. Und wenn ich so tagsüber so gucken will, wo geht denn jetzt gerade die Party ab, dann seh ich das halt einfach.
Ach, hier, Roddy wieder im Cyber-Sex-Teil.
Ich weiß, wer jetzt in den Zug guckt und so.
Ja, hier, Juri hängt da irgendwie an der Rakete ab. Warum ist der nicht hier? Ach nee, das ist nicht aktuell. Okay, deshalb ist ja noch kein Laden hier. Wird alles noch gesucht. Wie auch immer auf jeden Fall, Juri ist bestimmt hier, oder Juri? Das ist einfach praktisch. Das ist einfach, ich find das total super. Also wenn man so opt-in-mäßig da dabei sein kann und sich mit seiner Peer-Group so ein Realtime wer ist wo baut, dann wird einfach so ein Camp auch einfach viel... Ja, ist aber auch so.
Wenn wir jetzt hier auf einem ITF-Meeting wäre, würde jetzt da hinten der ACL Jumann aufstehen, ans Mikrofon gehen, sagen, ihr habt sie doch nicht mehr alle.
Die Frage ist ja immer, habe ich Wahl oder habe ich die Wahl nicht? Hier habe ich die Wahl und ich will ja auch die Wahl haben und ich will halt genauso schützen wie entschützen können.
Ja, aber das ist trotzdem eine schöne Anwendung, aber trotzdem, das machen ja alle schon. In vier Jahren hat jeder sein iPhone implantiert und dann ist es eh vorbei.
Nicht peer-to-peer ohne Infrastruktur. Hier geht das ja nur, weil du irgendwie so ein Netz und LTE und Mobilfunk und so weiter hast. Beziehungsweise manchmal eben auch nicht hast, weil wenn ich jetzt hier keinen WLAN hätte, was ich auch noch manchmal habe, dann bin ich halt schön in Edge-Land, Edge-Land. Hier gibt es für dich kein Netz. Du lebst in Edge-Land. Und dann war's das halt mit dem Tracking.
Wer von euch hat noch eine Rocket? Wer hat die in den letzten drei Monaten auch benutzt?
Wenige, wenige, wenige. Hier und da wird gesummt.
Aber die Rocket war halt auch kein Software Defined Radio.
Was ist mit der Peer-to-Peer-Nummer?
Die hat ja ein Radio drin, oder was?
Weil es halt keine Killer abgab. Weil einfach nur Blink-Lights-Movies auf der Rocket anzeigen, das reicht halt nicht. Du brauchst halt eine fucking Killer ab. Und ich sagte ja Peer-to-Peer mit irgendwie Tracking und Tra-la-la und bunt und jeder weiß, wo jeder ist.
Das ist geil.
Aber für mich funktioniert das.
Na, eine Killer ab, die mir sagt so, oh scheiße, wenn ich jetzt dieses Ding nicht jetzt, was ich sowieso habe, jetzt auch mal zusammenlöte, dann bin ich halt nicht mehr mit den coolen Kids unterwegs.
Aber kommt die Rocket da auch schon oder nicht?
Ich fände das aber...
Weiß ich nicht, aber es gibt die App nicht. Könnte oder könnte oder hätte, würde vielleicht, das ist das eine. Das andere ist, dass irgendwie da One-Button-Install, zack, bumm und dann...
Dann noch mal programmieren, Tim, und mach einfach mal.
Noch mal? Soll ich noch mal probieren?
Hat ja nicht gereicht, offensichtlich auch für die Apps.
Man ist nicht fertig mit Programmieren lernen.
Ich finde, man könnte das ja kombinieren. Hier gibt es ja Raketenbauer, habe ich gehört, die hier Raketen bauen, auf dem Camp auch. Und ja, die könnten die dann auch noch mal ein bisschen...
Das ist eine Self-Organization übrigens, ja. Es gibt auch Raketenbau für Kinder. Mit Schwarzpulver und allem Pippa Po.
Haben wir aber noch kein Schwarzpulver?
Die haben jetzt alle Raketen gebaut und warten jetzt da drauf, dass wir am Sonntag das Ding noch mal starten dürfen in kontrollierter Form.
Ich denke, die machen da nur so Co-Kleid-Mentos-Raketen oder so, oder?
Nee, stand Schwarzpulver im Workshop-Programm.
Okay.
Alle sehen, ganz ruhig.
Der Sandmann hat das Gate eingeschaltet.
Geil. Endlich kein Feedback mehr. Und kein Publikum mehr. Es ist wie in der Mitte eben, seid ihr noch da? Die TF hat da was richtig verstanden.
So, gibt es denn noch irgendwas, was wir über das Camp unbedingt berichten müssen? Fällt euch noch was ein.
Also ich muss noch sagen, dass für mich funktioniert diese Navigation und Leute finden einfach auch ohne dieses Mesh-Netzwerk, weil man muss einfach nur entweder an einer Stelle sitzen bleiben oder sich die ganze Zeit bewegen und dann kommen einem die Leute automatisch in die Arme. Letztens meinte auch schon einer, wie sie so ein Familien treffen und so. Aber es ist auch wirklich so, du triffst auch Leute, die hast du erst das letzte Mal beim Camp gesehen. Alle sind sie da und ich treff die halt auch alle. Und deswegen ist glaube ich auch das Camp jetzt fünf Tage, damit du auch wirklich alle triffst.
Weil man schon einen Tag braucht für Händeschützungen.
Kann aber sein, dass diesmal der fünfte Tag noch mehr fünfter Tag war als beim letzten Mal. Aber werden wir dann sehen, wie sich das entwickelt.
Das ist übrigens jetzt noch ein kleiner Pro-Tipp oder auch wieder von der Öffnungsveranstaltung. Haben wir das überhaupt gesagt? Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr. Ich glaube, das ist eine Sache, die wir vergessen haben. Für den Abbau gibt es gar nicht so viel Zeit.
Weil das Oldtimer-Treffen kommt.
Genau, da kommt nämlich nach uns ein Treckertreffen, wo alte Herrschaften, nee, alte Trecker von vielleicht auch jungen Herrschaften hergefahren werden und ausgestellt werden. Das heißt, wenn Fiona und ich unsere Abschlussveranstaltung da zelebriert haben, dann müsst ihr auch gleich schon eigentlich eure Sachen packen.
Nein, die müssen uns helfen beim Abbauen.
Naja, also unsere Sachen, alle Sachen.
Meine coole Apple Watch hat mir gerade erzählt, dass die Starterlaubnis für die Rakete morgen 11 Uhr ist.
Wenn es gewittert, ja.
Dual-Use.
Zwei Anwendungen.
So hip.
Das war's oder was? Da gibt's nichts zu sagen zum Camp.
Ja, du ist...
Thanks for coming.
Na, reden wir denn jetzt?
Da geht noch was.
Eine Stunde.
Hat er schon da schon? Haben wir noch, können wir noch aufzeichnen? Ja, ein bisschen noch, ne? Sollen wir noch ein bisschen weitermachen?
Das ist Verhalten.
Also nicht.
Ja, ich weiß jetzt auch nicht so ganz.
Wir machen mal ein bisschen Druck da drauf.
Uns fallen bestimmt noch ein paar Camp-Referenzen ein.
Genau.
Okay, wenn du was auf dem IETF Meeting......Meting....Meting.
Wieder mal.
Wieder mal. Weil du ja dreimal im Jahr bist.
Ich mach nicht alle mit, aber die so an diesen gammligen Locations. Nicht? Das war jetzt in Prag.
Ja, das ist auch hier.
Vor drei Wochen erst. War es sozusagen Heimspiel. War sehr interessant wieder mal. Wir hatten auch Sachen, die dem Camp zum Beispiel, oder nicht dem Camp, sondern dem Kongress noch nicht gelungen sind. Wir hatten nämlich am Sonntag sozusagen, an unserem Tag Null, hatten wir abends auch die Aufführung von Citizen Four mit anschließender Live-Schalte nach Moskau. Das war sehr interessant. Insbesondere fand ich halt eben, man kennt ihn auch aus den Interviews, er kommt so ein bisschen rüber als politischer Aktivist, aber der Typ ist halt am Ende des Tages auch Techniker. Der wusste sehr, sehr gut technisch, was da abgeht und hat eben auch einzelne Working Groups adressiert, was die da gemacht haben. Er hat auch Standing Ovation gekriegt. Was auch sehr lustig war, das hat ihm auch deutlich Spaß gemacht. Eigentlich die haben die Aufführung irgendwie um 22 Uhr gemacht und dann um Mitternacht ist sie gesagt, der läuft ja so zwei Stunden oder so. Mitternacht oder so war der Film dann rum. Und Moskau ist ja noch mal drei Stunden weg. Das heißt, das war ja schon relativ spät denn da bei ihm. Und dann hieß es so, naja, wir machen dann hier mal so drei Fragen oder sowas. Und das ging dann noch anderthalb Stunden oder so, weil immer mehr Spaß gehabt hat. Und manchmal, ach, eine Frage können wir noch. Und dann war halt sehr interessant.
Was für Fragen waren denn das?
Die sie an ihn gestellt haben oder so. Na, was denn so sein Tipp wäre für die ganze Standardisierung oder so. Weil ich sagte ja schon, er hat sich sehr bemüht, weil er nimmt auch so ein bisschen daran teil, was da so passiert in Sachen Standardisierung. Gerade so Verschlüsselung, so Zeugs. Und er hat halt eben angesagt, seine Message ist, ihr seht jetzt auch durch die Sachen, die jetzt da publik geworden sind, wird halt einfach alles abgehört, wo er nicht von vornherein fürsorgt, dass man es nicht tun kann. Also das, was wir machen, ist so uninteressant, das hört bestimmt keiner ab, was man so früher gedacht hat, das zählt halt einfach nicht. Und er hat sehr darauf auch beharrt, dass bei der Stabilisierung auch immer schön diese Sachen beachtet werden. Das ist auch das, was ich ja vorhin schon mal sagte, mit dem ACLU-Typen, den gibt's wirklich. Also die American Civil Liberties Union. Der ist da auch bei diesen Working Groups dabei. Und wenn da Protokolle so diskutiert werden, wo halt eben Nutzerdaten transportiert werden und da wird halt nicht ordentlich aufgepasst drauf. Oder man kann halt Drückschlüsse daraus ziehen auf Nutzerinformation. Dann steht der auf, stellt sich ans Mikrofon und sagt so, ihr gebt da gerade mal wieder Nutzerdatenpreis. Und alle so, ja, okay, gut, dann machen wir das anders. Und das fand ich halt sehr gut, dass da jetzt ganz deutlich mehr gegenüber früher auch drauf geachtet wird auf diese Dinge. Aber was wollten sie denn jetzt von ihm so wissen? Die übliche Frage war zum Beispiel, glaubst du, dass du jetzt doch noch mal demnächst mal nach Hause kommst? Und er so, naja, das ist ja ein laufendes Verfahren, da kann ich ja nichts über sagen, aber nö. Weil sie wollen ihn halt an den Arsch kriegen über ein Gesetz, wo du eigentlich nichts gegen sagen kannst, wo sozusagen die Regierung einfach eine Behauptung aufstellt. Ein Gesetz von, keine Ahnung, Anno Tuff, was so designt ist, dass die Regierung einfach behaupten muss, du bist eben böse und schadest dem Land, und deswegen gehst du lebenslang in den Knast. Da kannst du halt nicht viel gegen sagen. Deswegen hat er gesagt, da macht er sich momentan nicht so richtig viele Hoffnungen.
Okay, aber was war jetzt sozusagen ein technisches Interesse an ihm oder Einschätzung? War das jetzt nur so dieses, alles wird abgehört und sorg mal dafür oder ist er da auch mit seiner Expertise noch irgendwie anders befragt worden?
Es waren da nicht nähere technische Details, sondern waren eher so politische Fragen oder eben Einschätzungsdinge, wie er Dinge einschätzt zu solchen Themen, die aber eben alle auf die Sache hinaus liefen, dass er eben sagte, ja Leute, jetzt bitte passt ordentlich auf. Das, was ich hier mitgebracht oder was durch mich verbreitet wurde, ist nur die Spitze des Eisbergs. Seid halt eben einfach vorsichtig. Das hat er sehr eindringlich gesagt. Ich kann das jetzt nicht in einzelnen Worten wiedergeben. Das ist jetzt auch schon eine Weile her.
Aber der hat Spaß mit Nerd-Kommunikation. Also können wir ja auch mal im Kongress zuschalten und mal fragen, so Apple Watch und so.
Ich meine, inzwischen denke ich mal, die Geheimdienste wissen eh alle, wo er wohnt. Und diese Nummer, dass er jetzt in einem Keller sitzt ohne Fenster, ist jetzt auch schon rum. Und der macht eigentlich da ganzen Entspannten. Und ich denke, wenn man jetzt mal da höflich anfracht, kriegt man da bestimmt mal einen Interviewtermin.
Und was lief sonst noch so auf der ITF? Du bist ja mit so diversen Auguren mal wieder zusammen gestoßen.
Ja, ich hatte ja schon in der Freak Show, wo wir uns nach der WWDC dieses Video da angeguckt haben, hatte ich mir ja mal diesen Stuart Cheshire mal vorgeknüpft. Sehr, sehr netter Typ, sehr, sehr bodenständig auch. Haben uns ein bisschen unterhalten über die Themen, die Entwicklung. Ich hab ihm auch gesagt, dass wir das eben sehr schön fanden, dass ich mal jemand mal darum bemühe, dieses Schwanz beißt Hunden nochmal aufzulösen. Also dieses hier gibt es zwar einen technischen Standard, aber die Gerätehersteller implementieren den nicht, weil es gibt da kein Netz, was das kann. Und die Netzbetreiber sagen, ja, toller Standard, aber es gibt da keine Geräte, die das können. Warum soll ich das implementieren? Und dass das halt eben eine schöne Sache ist, die jetzt gerade Apple mal durchbricht mit ihrer Marktmacht, um da mal ein bisschen aus dem Kniff zu kommen. Und er hat mir aber auch zu verstehen gegeben, dass er das schon gerne auch nochmal lesen wollen würde, weil er möchte das gerne seinen Chefs zeigen. Also er hat es ein bisschen durch die Blume zu verstehen gegeben, dass die ihn zwar machen lassen, aber dass er schon gerne noch ein bisschen Support hätte aus der Community für solche Sachen. Oder dass ihm das gefallen würde, wenn er da irgendwie mal eine Zuschrift verkriegt. Hab ich ihm auch zugesagt. Wer da also auch gerne nochmal was hinschreiben möchte, der jetzt vielleicht was entdeckt dort, was die da machen, von den Apple-Leuten.
Hast du ihm unsere Show-Notes geschickt quasi von der Sendung?
Nee, aber das könnte man ja mal machen. Auf die Idee bin ich auch gar nicht gekommen. Was sonst auch sehr interessant war, insgesamt war, also das kann man ja vielleicht auch mal sagen, Apple und zum Beispiel Google bekriegen sich ja marketingmäßig. So Android versus iPhone und aber die arbeiten dort in den Working Groups sehr einträglich zusammen. Ich hab jetzt selber auch eine neue Working Group mitgegründet, die sich so ein bisschen befasst damit, dass wir diese scheiße WLAN-Portale mal irgendwie weg oder in den Griff kriegen. Wir werden sie, sagen wir mal, nicht komplett wegkriegen, weil es gibt halt Themen, die derzeitigen, die die derzeit technischen Standards nicht abdecken. Wie zum Beispiel diese so, manche Länder, die sowas haben, so wie Störerhaftungen oder so ein Scheiß, wo du halt aus rechtlichen Gründen irgendwie einen Haken setzen musst, sagen ja, ich mache hier keinen bösen Bit-Torrent oder sowas, bla bla bla. Soweit lassen halt die derzeitigen Standards nicht zu, aber es geht halt genauer darüber, dass eben so, dass wenn schon ein Portal da ist, dass er dann mit dem Gerät kommuniziert und sagt, hier bitte zeigt dem User mal hier folgende Text und lasse ihn da klicken und dann ist gut, aber dass man jetzt nicht anfängt, immer diese komischen, über diese Browser-Geschichten. Es ist ja das Ärgerliche an diesen WLAN-Portalen, dass du erstmal einen Browser starten musst, der natürlich einen nicht verschlüsselten Request machen muss. Da musst du also erst mal mit HTTP irgendwo hingreifen, wo wir ja gerade auf der anderen Seite dabei sind, jetzt alle zu verschlüsseln. Das heißt deine Standardseite, deine Google oder sonst welche ist ja alle schon lange verschlüsselt, das geht alles nicht. Das heißt, du musst jetzt noch einen Web-Sauber finden, der nur HTTP mit dir spricht, den ansprechen, um dann vom Portal redirected zu werden auf eine dämliche Seite, die niemals auf das Device draufpasst, auf das iPhone oder auf das iPad oder was auch immer du hast. Und inzwischen dich alle deine anderen Programme angreischen, dein E-Mail kleint, wie er sagt ne, die kann mir an den Server nicht aus. Und dein Kalender kleint und alles. Und diese ganze Geschichte, dass man das mal ein bisschen in den Griff kriegt. Und das fand ich sehr interessant, weil da waren wie gesagt auch die, wirklich die Leute, die den Code für iOS schreiben, den Code für Android schreiben, waren auch mit dabei. Und die sitzen dann da zusammen und sagen, so wie macht ihr denn das? Und die machen, okay, das finde ich schon irgendwie ganz okay.
Gibt es denn da jetzt schon einen Ansatz für den Standard?
Nee, der Standard sind wir noch weit weg. Wir sammeln halt erstmal, das war die Gründung von so einer, das war erstmal ein BOV, sozusagen Birds Over Feather Session. Und da wurde dann auch durch Summe eben abgestimmt, dass wir sagen, wir machen da draus eine Working Group. Und unterhalten uns jetzt sowohl mit den Portal-Herstellern auf der einen Seite als auch mit den Geräteherstellern auf der anderen Seite, um halt die Sachen hinzubringen, die man hin will. Inclusive Payment und so. Also erstmal natürlich dieses Zugang und abnicken, ja ich mach hier nichts Böses und la und so. Aber auch das Wiedererkennen von Geräten gerade. Das ist ja zum Beispiel auch der Nerv. Selbst wenn du durch die Scheiße einmal durchgegangen bist, du klappst dein Laptop mal zu oder gehst mal zum Mittagessen und kommst wieder, geht der Scheiß wieder von vorne los. Und all solche Sachen, dass das mal ein bisschen aus dem Kniff kommt.
Und Hamni, hast du sie mal befragt zu der Motivation mit dem IPv6? Ob sie da so richtig drücken wollen? Weiß man schon, dass jetzt irgendwie alle das supporten müssen, damit du Twitter noch benutzen kannst und so?
Meinst du jetzt die Apple-Jahner? Die Android-Vöge sind sowieso IPv6-Apologeten. Die Leute, die das machen. Aber Cheshire sowieso, der ist auch voll mit dabei. Deswegen sagte ich, aber das wäre halt schön, wenn er noch ein bisschen Backing kriegen würde aus der Community. Weil ich denke, der ist halt ewig da. Dem lassen sie ein bisschen Spielraum, was zu machen in seiner Firma. Aber er steht natürlich auch, wie alle Leute, die schon ewig in so einem Unternehmen sind, immer so ein bisschen unter Beschuss. Das muss denn alles neuer und toller und besser werden. Wir haben das gesehen, zum Beispiel bei Yosemite, haben sie ja dieses Bonjour kaputt gemacht, indem sie da diesen tollen, wie hieß der? Discovery Demon dahin gebaut haben. Ein wohl dem Vernehmen nach unglaublich grottenschlechtes Stück Software. Auch innerhalb von Apple so gesehen, wurde dann aber immer weiter gepusht, bis dann irgendwann ein anderes Liberty mal Tim Cook angerufen hat, gesagt, sag mal, geht's noch?
Eine was hat angerufen? Eine Celebrity.
Eine Celebrity. Ich kann doch sagen, das war Wind Surf, also sozusagen der Uropa des Internets. Hat dann mal bei Tim Cook angerufen, hat gesagt, ey Alter, meine Drucker drucken hier nicht, geht's noch? Revolution kann so einfach sein. Pass auf, die Story geht noch weiter. Dann hat Tim Cook natürlich so seine Chain runter angerufen, dann klingelte natürlich bei Stuart das Telefon. Und er so, ja, ich hab da meinen MDNS-Responder geschrieben, der würde funktionieren, aber ich versuch das mal zu debuggen. Und während die beiden dann da machten, also Stuart und Wind, kam dann Wind einfach auf die Idee und hat gesagt, pass auf, wir nehmen jetzt mal aus einer alten OSX-Release den MDNS-Responder und lassen den laufen. Und in dem Moment druckte das und Tim Cook rief an. Und der Drucker lief im Hintergrund. Und er so, pass mal auf, Alter, du machst jetzt einfach den MDNS-Responder wieder drauf. Und so geschah es dann auch. Aber es hat ewig gedauert, es hat Monate gedauert. Es gibt ja, wenn so unter OSX...
Habt ihr die Hack aber schon vorher rausgefunden?
Ja, ja.
Also das ist sozusagen die Lösung. Wenn man jetzt so ein Problem hat mit dem Apple, dann muss man einfach nur den Erfinder des Internets anrufen lassen bei Apple und dann läuft es wieder.
Wenn du, es gibt noch so andere nette Infos dazu, wenn auf so einem Apple-Ding was abstürzt und du das nicht ausgeknipst hast, dann schickt es dir ein Report nach Hause. Diese Automatic-Bug-Report, la la la. Und die werden auch wirklich bearbeitet und sortiert. Man denkt immer, die gehen da direkt nach Def Null. Nein, nein, die werden statistisch ausgewertet, zusammengefasst nach gleichen Problemen und so weiter und so fort. Und dieser Discovery-Demon hat über vier Monate hinweg von... Nee, die Top Ten belegt. Alle, alle, alle. Weil das Ding halt an jeder Stelle abstürzt. Überall. Das hat nicht bloß einen Wachs, das stürzt halt dauernd und überall ab.
Wurden die Zuständigen denn gestieft?
Dem von dem nach nicht, nein.
Mit dem Discovery-Demon hatte der Cheshire nix zu tun.
Nee, der hat halt seine MDNS... Die haben es immer gesagt, kannst du das mal in den Ohren bringen? Er so, ja, nehmt einfach mal einen MDNS-Responder. Der Ding ist halt alt, aber Single-Threaded ist ein Simplet, so wie man früher programmiert hat. So in C und dann so mit Select oder Poll oder so. Single-Threaded, mehrere Sachen, go to fail, ja. Und das andere Ding haben sie halt irgendwelche Hipster zusammenhacken lassen, die meinen, oh, das muss alles Multithreaded sein und Locking oder seh mal vorne brauchen wir nicht, deswegen stürzt das auch dauernd immer ab. Weil jetzt sich dauernd immer selber seine Daten überschreibt mit anderen Fats, also ganz, ganz übel, das Ding. Mit Herr Lang wär das nicht passiert. Aber aus politischen Gründen wollten sie das halt eben unbedingt durchprügeln. Ja, also da gab's wie gesagt noch diverse Sachen. Eine Sache, die ich ganz interessant fand, von der wir jetzt gerade noch mal bei ITF sind, ich hatte ja vorhin das erwähnt mit diesen DNS-Geschichten im V6 und DHCP und so weiter. Android macht kein DHCP V6. Und ich hab die dann gefragt, wieso denn eigentlich nicht? Das ist ja jetzt nicht so schwer. Und die so, ja, das hat Gründe, weil man kann mit DHCP V6 nicht nur DNS-Server-Adressen vermitteln, sondern man kann auch Geräten-Adressen zuweisen. Normalerweise ist das ja das, wie gesagt, wenn wir mit SLAC arbeiten wie hier, da sagt das Netz ja nur, hier hast du so einen 64-Bit-Bereich und da addierst du dir noch mal selber eine selbst ausgedachte 64-Bit-Adresse hinzu, um dann die gesamte IPv6-Adresse zu bilden. Das heißt, das Gerät sucht sich selber eine Adresse und wechselt die auch andauernd, so für Privacy und so weiter. Wenn du das Netz so einstellst, dass du sagst, nee, du darfst das nicht, bitte geh mal hin zum DHCP-Server, hol dir mal eine feste Adresse, denkt man erst mal, das ist ja toll, das möchte ich haben. So die Admins denken das. Es gibt aber auch andere Leute, die das gerne denken. Es gibt nämlich zum Beispiel Leute von der Content-Mafia. Die rennen jetzt nämlich inzwischen rum, bei großen Organisationen wie Universitäten und so, die so größere Netze betreiben und versuchen, die zu belabern. Sie möchten auch bitte DHCPv6 benutzen, statt SLAC.
Damit man besser tracken kann.
Damit man besser tracken kann, wer jetzt hier welche BitTorrents und so laufen lässt.
Großmutter, warum hast du nur einen DHCP-Server?
Und das ist zumindestens eine der Begründungen, die mir die Android-Leute gesagt haben, warum sie sagen, in diesem Druck wollen sie sich jetzt derzeit nicht beugen. Sie machen das nicht an oder wenn sie das anmachen, machen sie nur so andere Mechanismen an. Aber diese Adress-Fahrgabe wollen sie halt nicht. Unter anderem schon deswegen, weil sie dauernd Druck von ihrem Management kriegen, weil dauernd irgendwelche Leute von der MPAA oder sonst wo anrufen, sagen, mach doch das mal da rein. Finde ich immer sehr interessant. Also wenn man dann so ganz hinten um drei Ecken gedacht, ja, das ist eigentlich eine Technik, wo man denkt, tut doch niemandem was, doch tut doch niemandem was.
Warum hat sich dann ausgerechnet Google, ist das dann Googles Entscheidung?
Nein, wenn du da mal richtig reinzoomst, ne, pass auf, wenn du da mal richtig reinzoomst, dann sind die Typen, die das hacken, sind nicht irgendwelche Leute in Nadelstreifenanzügen mit Schlipsen, sondern die sehen so aus, so.
Vielleicht hier gerade eine. Wir kommen von denen.
Und die das immer so ist mit solcher Software, die, wenn du da tief genug drin steckst, dann bist du halt eben auch nicht so einfach zu ersetzen. Und dann haben die halt, dann sind die zwar Nerds am Ende der Foodchain, aber dann sagt das Management, hallo, wir wollen aus kommerziellen oder politischen Gründen gerne, dass du das tust. Und dann sagt der zum Beispiel, nö. Und das finde ich dann auch wieder cool, dass die Google-Jahner ihn da nicht einfach ausschmeißen. Da wüsste ich ein paar andere Firmen, die würden das dann einfach machen. Und der sagt halt einfach... Da hab ich jetzt keine Lust. Da sagt der einfach, da hab ich jetzt keine Lust drauf. Und dann macht der das einfach nicht.
Hörst du es nicht?
Vielleicht. Ruf den doch alle mal an.
Außerdem hast du auf jeden Fall gerade angehen mit deiner Uhr. Du kannst doch mit deiner Uhr dein Telefon anhängen.
Hätte ich jetzt auch gleich gemacht.
Du kannst den Airplane-Mode nur nicht wieder ausschalten über die Uhr.
Also es gibt noch 1.003 Anekdoten, aber die anderen Kollegen möchten vielleicht auch noch was beitragen. Ich möchte jetzt meine Cola trinken.
Ja, wir müssen mal hier über Bier reden. Willst du mit in die Sendung oder was? Ja, ruf an, ihr könnt so was erzählen.
Ja, da legt er wieder auf.
Aber immerhin hast du Netz.
Ich wollt ja nur aus dem Edge raus. Bin ich jetzt auch raus. Kann man dieses scheiß FaceTime immer ausschalten.
Diese Fliege da von deinem Display weg machen, das nervt mich total. Mein OCD springt da voll an. Darf ich mal?
Hopfenkurs, ja.
Ist wirklich sehr hopfig. Naturtrübes, untergegeriges Vollbier, wo kommt das her?
Ich bin kurz vor der Sendung von jemandem angesprochen worden und hab diesen Sixpack in die Hand gedrückt bekommen. Genau, da drüben sitzt er. Vielen Dank.
Sehr lecker.
Oh, es gibt einen Tanz.
Kann ich das auch mal probieren?
Ich sag mal noch was dazu.
Tim?
Was wie?
Kann ich deinen Hopfenkurs auch mal?
Der Hopfenkurs ist schon durch.
Der ist schon durch. Ich hab keinen weiteren Hopfenkurs.
Hopfenkurs ist untertrieben. Also es war ein Geknutsche.
Hopfenknutsch.
Hopfenzungenkurs.
Hopfenpferdekuss.
Wir waren intim.
Es gibt einen Clemens.
Ich hab sie sehr nah an mich herangelassen. Und jetzt gibt es hier Fidelio.
Den hab ich auch.
Brauerei Herle, Leutkirch. Ich weiß noch nicht mal, wo das ist.
Irgendwo, wo sie lecker Bier machen.
Eine helle Freude. Bio und alles. Sehr schön.
Mit Soße und Schar.
Clemens meinte, ich sollte das noch mal kurz erwähnen. Ach so, es gibt Clemens Bier?
Ne, das solltest du nicht erwähnen. Es hat jemand offensichtlich ein Transkript erstellt von diesem Edward Snowden at ITF 93. Genau. Weil man hat ihm wohl zugesagt, dass das nicht aufgezeichnet wird. Deswegen gibt es keine Aufzeichnung. Keine offizielle Aufzeichnung.
Das gibt's auf GitHub, den Link gibt's im Chat. Ich denke mal, das dürfte die Show-Notes-Kruschen eingesammelt haben. Okay, next. Dennis, was ist jetzt mit deinem Bitcoin-Zelt?
Das ist von der Ecke da vorne schräg durch am Ende. So ein weißes Zelt.
Und was findet da statt? Gibt's da so eine Art Bank?
Da ist ein Sofa da. Ich war da gestern nur mal ganz kurz.
Sagen wir mal, laufender Bitcoin-Maschinen. Es gibt ja einen Grund, warum der Generator da hingestellt ist.
Wahrscheinlich, ja. Ey, Alter. Die haben so ein paar USB-Mainer am Start.
Aber wieso gibt es hier keinen Bitcoin-Automaten?
Wollen die auch besorgen. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob es schon geklappt hat.
Aber so Bitcoin spielt ja auch irgendwie keine Rolle.
Nee, jetzt geht es jetzt hier und Bitcoin ist irgendwie nicht so. FIFA hat gesagt, verbraucht so viel Strom und dann geht das nicht. Ja, weiß ich nicht, das liegt ja auch an euch. Also ich meine, wenn ihr mehr Bitcoin macht, also ihr seid ja der CCC, ich bin das ja nicht alleine. Also ihr könnt schon auch das einfach benutzen und mehr Anfragen stellen und dann geht das. Aber ein Grund, was ich gehört habe, ist, warum wir für den Eintritt keine Bitcoins nehmen müssen, weil wir haben ja auch unseren Kreditkartenprovider, der irgendwie eure Abrechnung macht und der kann keinen Bitcoin und sie wollten nicht noch einen zweiten, der halt Bitcoin kann, weil das halt dann nervig wäre. Das wäre wohl ein Grund.
Ja, wahrscheinlich wäre es jetzt auch nicht so nennenswert gewesen, was darüber an Umsatz läuft, nehme ich mal an.
Aber du hättest trotzdem den Ärger mit dem Finanzamt gehabt.
Bestimmt.
Du hast da keinen Ärger. Du kannst doch, du kriegst die genauso wie bei den Kreditkarten, deine Überweisung rein und kannst genau sagen, das kam rein. Du kriegst doch am Ende die Dollars oder Euros direkt, so du siehst, du bitcoinst ja gar nicht.
Genau, die bieten nur sozusagen im Frontend für Bitcoin und bei dir landet dann eben nur der harte Euro. Also was ist noch da für nürrig geblieben?
Aber die machen da in ihrem Zelt... Ihr seid alle Individuen. Nee, aber die haben gestern einen Film gezeigt da, so ein Bitcoin-Movie, den hab ich selber auch noch nicht gesehen. Dann sind da wohl ein bisschen Vorträge, die wollen mich da auch noch einspannen, wollten eigentlich, dass ich einen Vortrag halte, aber ich hab keinen Vortrag über meinen Bitcoin-Pool. Aber ich werd mich da morgen wohl hinbegeben und so eine Art Ask Me Anything machen, so ähnlich, über Pools und Mining, so ein bisschen. Und ich weiß noch nicht, wann das ist, weil ich nicht genau weiß, jetzt wann morgen meine Schichten sind und wann die Zeit haben, aber die haben so ein Zettel am Zelt dran, wo dransteht, was sie so als Programm haben und wann man da so kommen kann und so. Ich mach Hinterzimmerkasse, ja. Das müsst ihr euch so vorstellen wie bei Scarface, da stehen die großen Geräte auf dem Tisch, dann kommen da so Leute mit so riesen Säcken rein und ich mach dann die ganze... und dann macht es ding und dann hab ich so ein Bündel in der Hand.
Dann gibt's noch so ein Spiegel mit weißem Pulver und... Deswegen wädert denn es auch so viel.
Ihr wisst gar nicht, wie viele Schienen so komisch und nur auf einer Seite so ganz hart geknickt sind und auf der anderen Seite dann immer weniger. Verstehst du nicht. 80 Euro.
Don't talk about it. Gibt's noch was zu sagen zum Thema Geld? Digital oder real?
Prinzipiell, wir haben Duschcontainer, wir haben Klo-Container, wir haben geiles Essen und so, aber so ein Geld-Automat-Container, dat wärt.
Oder überhaupt noch ein Geld-Automat, ne?
Was ich noch sagen kann, was es an der Kasse noch gibt, es gibt Duschmarken für die Marina, da sind wohl so Profi-Duschen, so kann man das nennen, dafür könnt ihr euch Marken an der Kasse holen. Fünf Stücken Zehner oder irgendwie so.
Was heißt Profi-Duschen?
Na ja, besser als hier, sonst müsste man sich die Marken...
Noch besser als hier?
Ja, was heißt denn das?
Ein Stück für Männer, zwei Duschen. Okay, aber was heißt denn Profi-Duschen? Dann wird man so gesandt strahlt.
Wir haben da so 100 Münzen oder so, das muss schon irgendwie ein bisschen größer sein.
Das Wasser ist warm wahrscheinlich.
Vielleicht, und vielleicht ist keine Schlange da vorne. Und man hat Platz, um seine Sachen hinzuhängen.
Vielleicht sogar eine Bank, um sie hinzulegen.
Ihr könnt es ja mal austesten und dann weiterverbreiten, wenn es cool war oder nicht.
Genau, für die nächsten Live-Show auf dem nächsten Camp.
Es gibt ja hier auch noch ein Open-Street-Map. Wenn ich es richtig sehe, ist das Open-Street-Map basiert. Genau, hier Campmap.dot. Ich fang nochmal von vorne an. Campmap.masdermind mit Z.
Fangen wir nochmal von vorne an.
Da wollte sich niemand nicht das nennen.
Matsdermind.
Es gibt da eine Map, da kann man sich irgendwie eintragen. Ist ganz praktisch, aber da sind noch nicht alle eingetragen. Aber wie ist denn jetzt die URL?
Mach doch mal einen QR-Code an die Wand. Warum ist der Beamer eigentlich nicht an?
Weiß ich nicht, kann ich da was hinschicken?
Der kann keine hoch aufgelösten QR-Cards.
Soll ich keine QR-Code hinschicken?
Der soll einfach mal Text anzeigen. Was reinpasten. Wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall kann man hier so eine interaktive Campmap erstellen. Und das wäre eigentlich ganz cool, wenn sich alle Villages hier noch eintragen würden, weil dann würde man zumindest danach auch noch mal wissen, was wo ist.
Wo man was gefunden hätte, wenn man denn...
Genau, wenn man denn irgendwie Zeit gehabt hätte. Ich schau jetzt gerade mal, ob wir noch irgendwas Wichtiges vergessen haben. Ja, ah, da ist das Belgian Village. Das hab ich die ganze Zeit gesucht. Echt, das hab ich vorher nicht gefunden. Weil sie meinten im Wiki, sie wären nur im Westen. Das fand ich dann doch ein bisschen ungenau. Na, jetzt hab ich's.
Bist du wohl auch noch nicht genug rumgelaufen?
Nee, bin ich noch nicht, weil es ja auch groß hier. Also es ist ja wirklich nicht...
Wer von euch alles mit Fahrrad hier?
Na, ich.
War aber nicht so viel.
Dennis, weißt du eigentlich, wer sich diese Straßennamen hat einfallen lassen?
Ich hab so eine Ahnung. Die saßen nämlich in einem Club und kamen dann. Ja, wie wollen wir die Straßen nennen? Illuminati oder Gibson? Da hab ich gesagt, ey Jungs, seit 20 Jahren immer die gleiche Scheiße. Macht mal irgendwas anderes. Und dann haben sie auch was anderes gemacht.
Ja, und was haben sie jetzt gemacht? Irgendwelche Wissenschaftler, die keinen Schwein kennen. Und Wissenschaftlerinnen. Danke, richtiger Einwand von rechts.
Und gibt's jetzt die Hedil am Marschstraße, oder wie sie heißt?
Weiß ich nicht. Also ich muss zugeben, dass ich die wenigsten davon kannte. Genau, genau.
Ja, darum geht's ja. Du sollst ja kennenlernen.
Ja, nee, das ist ja auch in Ordnung. Aber hast du schon mal hinterher geklickt?
Ich hab noch nicht mal ein Straßenschild gesehen.
Die hängen aber seit zwei Tagen.
Ich wurde von einem Kollegen schon über ein paar aufgeklärt. Zum Beispiel den Namensgeber für Algorithmus haben wir hier als Straßennamen.
Und welcher ist das?
Der Al-Kwarizmi.
Dank für die Aussprache.
Wahrscheinlich. Al-Kwarizmi-Alleh. Ich wollte nicht sagen, dass es schlecht ist.
Also es ist besser als Illuminati und Gipsenstraßennamen.
Ja. Das stimmt. Das ist gut.
Tim ist befriedet.
Ist ja in Ordnung.
Und wonach sind die Veranstaltungsorte benannt?
Also die Datenklots sind nach Städten benannt.
Nicht alle.
Wie hieß unser hier Klemenz, wo wir gestern gepumelt hatten?
Warschau. Aber war die Kulfine wieder korrekt geschrieben. Also immer so in Landessprache.
W-A-R-S-A-W?
Oder doch nicht? Überlegereiweiß trotzdem. Ich glaube, es ist jedenfalls Warschauer. Unsere Daten gehen hier ins Warschauer Datenklo.
Ich denke, wir haben nichts mehr zu erzählen, oder? Nee, das ist alles keine Themen.
Das ist alles scheiße.
Das verdient den Namen Themen ab.
Das können wir jetzt nicht bringen.
Du weißt gar nicht, was das hier ist.
Nein, das ist einfach Kleinkram. Was ist denn das hier?
Hast du das eingeschragen?
Müssen wir uns darüber unterhalten?
Ich finde ihn irgendwie nett. Ich reiß das mal kurz an.
Und ihr wisst was, kurz anreißen bei Klemmenszeit. Holt euch noch ein Getränk.
Regie bitte, wie viel Aufzeichnungszeit haben wir noch? Naja, höchstens noch eine Stunde. Habt ihr doch keine Hektik? Also nur ganz kurz, für all die Leute, die hier gerne auch mit Raspberry Pis und ähnlichen Kleingedöns rumbasteln. Ich mach ja auch schon seit längerem was damit und erzeuge auch Software dafür. Wie viele auch schon mal gehört haben, bastel ich auch gerne mit Routern rum. Da gibt's ja auch Router, für die man auch selber Code generieren kann. Also ich rede jetzt hier von Arm- und Mips-Plattformen und so Zeugs. Und man kann jetzt entweder versuchen, direkt auf dem Raspberry Pi Sachen zu kompilieren. Da wird man aber alt und grau dabei, das ist richtig böse. Man kann auch versuchen, den Raspberry Pi zu emulieren. Da gibt es aber bisher nur so QEMO-Variante davon. Die emuliert nur den kleinsten Pi, der da raus ist. Und das auch sehr langsam. Und es gibt ein Projekt namens P-Root. Ich glaube die Webseite dazu ist proot.me. Und die haben ein super geiles, super einfach zu bedienendes Tool erzeugt, mit dem man sich auf einer normalen Intel-basierten Linux-Kiste eine Laufzeitumgebung erstellen kann mit wirklich nur drei Kommando-Zeilenparametern und vielleicht zwei Mausklicks oder sowas, die einem eine Umgebung erzeugt, wo man sich quasi in einem Pi befindet, aber mit den gesamten Ressourcen dieser Maschine, also mit nCPUs und so und so viel Gigabyte RAM und so weiter und so fort, sodass man eben auch mal schön make-j6 sagen kann und so. Damit bin ich also jetzt ganz froh dabei, für alle möglichen Mini-Plattformen Code zu erzeugen, Kernel zu erzeugen und so weiter und so fort. Wer, wie gesagt, einfach nur der Profi-Tipp für Leute, die damit basteln, klickt mal auf peroot.me.
Sie befinden sich in einem Pi.
Sie befinden sich in einem Pi. Also es ist wohlgemerkt, dass es jetzt keine Cross-Compilation-Umgebung, weil das ist ja auch immer so ein Nerv und so, sondern das ist halt sehr sexy. Ja, du guckst auf die Uhr, deswegen kann ich jetzt nicht näher darauf eingehen.
Ich gucke auf die Uhr, weil jemand im Chat meinte, ich soll irgendwas über die Uhr erzählen, und ich weiß aber nicht genau, was ich über die Uhr erzählen soll. Roddy, willst du nicht mal was über die Uhr erzählen?
Wir haben doch schon mal 2 Stunden über die Uhr geredet und sind dafür gehauen worden.
Aber hier, im Chat gibts was richtig Schönes, ein Wimmelbild vom Camp.
Das gibt es nicht nur im Chat, das gibt es sogar als Plakat.
Irgendjemand hat gemeint, dass die Künstlerin heute da war und man hätte sich signieren lassen können.
Die Künstlerin heute da war, die ist immer da. Die ist hier Teilnehmerin des Foxy Tellic.
Ja gut, aber die ist vielleicht nicht die ganze Zeit an der Bude und wartet auf Leute mit einem Stift in der Hand.
Das kann natürlich sein. Weiß irgendjemand, wo es das gibt?
Auf den Schirm.
Ja, gibt keinen Schirm. Ich glaube, ich selber das Wimmelbild.
Doch, eigentlich gibt es einen Schirmer. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir den jetzt irgendwie noch anschließen können.
Man kann ja noch erwähnen, wo ihr hier gerade sitzt, ist eigentlich der CCCB aus Berlin. Und wenn jetzt einer in den CCCB geht, dann geht dann nicht mal mehr das Licht an, es ist auch nicht mehr da.
Ist alles am Gebäude.
Die Leinwand ist irgendwie von da.
Das Display. Die Couches, LED-Lichter. Also alles.
Der komplette CCCB. Was natürlich eine einmalige Gelegenheit wäre, mal sauber zu machen.
Ist aber leider keiner da.
Aber das haben wir gemacht.
Der Kärcher ist auch hier.
Wir haben noch nicht sauber gemacht, aber wir haben einfach so viel mitgenommen in der Hoffnung, dass es nicht wieder zurückkommt.
Hätte man nicht hier noch zu den anderen Open-Air-Veranstaltungen fahren sollen und nochmal irgendwie ein kompletter, sieh mal, toller Zeug auspolen, von dem anderen in die Wette ranschleppen sollen.
Nee, das wollen die wieder haben. Da mussten wir auch sehr vorsichtig ausladen, weil es ist alles Kunst. Das ist ja schön.
Wollen wir jetzt am Ende?
Ja, aber was ist denn hier danach los als Programm, damit unsere Zuhörer und Gucker jetzt wissen, was wir jetzt machen danach?
Ich hab jetzt ein Programmhinweis gleich in 9 Minuten.
Jetzt schick die nicht alle weg, wir wollen hier noch ordentlich Bier ausgegeben bekommen.
Ja, das auch. Erst Bier und dann gibt es aber einen Vortrag zum Thema Musik machen mit Tesla-Spulen, wo jemand Tesla-Coils mit MIDI-Interface in Ableton eingebunden hat. Ja, nee, nicht hier, aber gibt es jetzt in einem Saal noch das letzte?
Na toll, jetzt sind sie alle weg.
Jetzt wäre das die geile Party geworden und jetzt wollen sie alle Tesla-Spulen angucken.
Das ist schon ein geiles Thema auf jeden Fall.
Na, wenn er sie mit MIDI und Ableton anschließt, wird er sie wohl dabei haben. Oder meinst du, der zeigt da nur eine Folie?
Die verbrauchen glaube ich ein bisschen Strom.
Weißt du, warum der Generator tanzt?
Der Fernsehturm, das ist es!
Es gibt hier ein Bastelprojekt, wo die so Beißhölzer machen. Oder so Beißstangen oder so. Wo man dann über die Knochenübertragung da so Sachen hört. Da basteln die mit so einem kleinen Elektromotor und so einem kleinen Leistungsverstärker was. Und dann beißt du auf so eine Stange da drauf und kriegst da den Sound dann, ohne dass die anderen das hören, kriegst du den Sound.
Ich dachte, das wäre für, wenn das mit den Strom-Experimenten schief geht, dass man...
So könnte man ja mal so eine Freak Show Podcast-Hörer-Event machen. So, hier ist dein Beißholz zum Zuhören.
Wir wissen nichts über System D, aber wir raten trotzdem drüber.
Ich glaube, jetzt haben wir unser Pulver verschossen. Also ich bin...
Jetzt werde ich langsam warm, ehrlich gesagt.
Was kommt denn?
Ich sehe das ja auch. Wie immer schlaft der Tim zuerst ab.
Ja, aber dann lass dir noch was einfallen, dass sie nicht alle besser aufstehen.
Jetzt hör dann nach auf dieser Bühne.
Ich weiß ja jetzt nicht nach.
Und es kommt einfach wie immer Sinnflut.
Können die da vorne und dann nicht sich ja so reinquatschen und dann sagen, was kommt?
Nicht heraufbeschwören. Die sind schon eingeschlafen. Hallo, das ist eine Open-Air-Veranstaltung, nicht Sinnflut heraufbeschwören.
Ja, Sinnflut kommt morgen. Morgen gibt es ja irgendwie NSFW auf der Bühne und es wird wahrscheinlich regnen, das wird lustig.
Jörnchen kommt. Wo denn?
Hier? Oder was?
In einer Stunde habe ich.
Ich finde die Information, die da angezeigt wird, finde ich jetzt gerade verwirrend.
Peter, jetzt sag doch mal was.
Regie.
Regie. Mats ab. Was kommt als nächstes?
Rainer, fahr ab.
Als nächstes legt jetzt Jörnchen gleich auf.
Dicker Beat und diesmal aber mit Limit, aber wir waren zu laut.
Genau. Und nicht wie früher, sondern wie in der Zukunft, so mit Tanzen und so. Ich finde das total großartig, wie viele Leute jetzt gekommen sind, keine Ahnung, es sind wahrscheinlich mehrere tausend. Und offensichtlich werdet ihr diesen Podcast und ich finde das total großartig. Und wir bedanken uns total auch für super Feedback und super Support und Tipps. Und Gesumme.
Gesumme.
Bier, Spenden, Klicks, Aufmerksamkeit, dumme Kommentare, dumme Kommentare, alles Mögliche. Das sind Hörer, die man haben will.
Das sind Camp-Besucher, die man haben will generell.
Höhrende Camp-Besucher.
Alles total super. Das war's. Freak Show. Live vom Camp. Vielen Dank. Und ihr hört uns bald wieder. Hat Spaß gemacht.
Dieses Podcast, schon verrückt, ne?